so uh yesterday was really awesome
because we did this show and we didn't
know what's going to happen with liz
cheney and then right around like 9 25
or whatever jack is like it's in they're
calling it liz cheney lost and i was
like what it's like four percent
reporting how is that possible and uh
yeah not only did she lose she lost by
38 points
wow what was she thinking well good news
for that 28
of wyoming that really likes liz cheney
she's thinking about running for
president and she has already launched
the great task uh-huh yeah well good
luck i guess she's gonna start making
money off democrats people are pointing
out that it's basically the lincoln
project so we'll talk about that i think
perhaps the big news today was that
china is sending it has deployed its
troops to russia for joint military
drills with belarus and india and
tajikistan and other countries
and uh
they say it's nothing to do with what's
going on in this you know regional
international conflict technically
because you got china uh china doing
military drills with russia obviously
ukraine and taiwan play a huge role in
this a second us delegation went to
taiwan china has ramped up its drills
been firing missiles over the country
which is an act of hostility because
they're basically blockading the island
and uh yeah you know we decided to leave
with liz cheney because it's more fun
and i don't know
i kind of feel like the world's ending
in world war iii and all that so we'll
talk about it before we get started my
friends please head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen from
biotrust you get it for 51 off today
over at stronger bones in life this is
what you need for your joints for your
skin for your hair hair for your nails
i've been i've been going super healthy
man uh as you know i i've been doing the
keto stuff from biotrust i've been
taking this multi-collagen stuff i like
mixing into my drinks and coffee and
things like that and uh i've been having
a good time i've been skating a lot and
i feel uh
feel incredible that's probably a
combination of everything but again
stronger bones in life.com and you will
get a 60 day money back guarantee the
healthy aging support of collagen and
its ideal forms five key types of
collagen you need from four different
sources
for every order today biotrust will
donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it's non-gmo and free of
artificial colors flavors preservatives
and sweeteners free of gluten
antibiotics and rbgh and rbst nearly no
odor or taste and there's no clumping
you'll get free shipping with every
order free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free new
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order shout out stronger
bones and life and also head over to
timcast.com
and become a member you'll get access to
our exclusive uncensored after show
which will be up tonight around 11. we
do that monday through thursday and you
can watch the silly behind-the-scenes
stuff like we have with welcome to the
cast castle cass castle the promo
episode giving you a tour of the house
showing you the people who work here and
we have a special guest jack posobic in
the episode it's really fun you check it
out and uh smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends joining us to talk
about the failures that are liz that is
liz cheney is greg price great to be
back what a great day this is for our
country one of the worst neocon
warmongers in the history of dc has been
defeated and not just her but her entire
family the dynasty of the cheneys that
have spent years just you know sending
people to die in pointless wars overseas
what a great day this is and so i just
want to propose a toast
to the end of the bush dynasty all right
the end of the clinton dynasty and now
the end of the cheney dynasty donald
trump did all that and god bless him for
it and we can we can say august 16th is
the end of dynasty day and uh you know
celebrate yeah
we also got libby she's hanging out hey
what's going on everybody glad to be
here libby emmons editor-in-chief of the
post-millennial
happy to hang out yeah happy to have you
libby yeah glad to be around ian
crossland up in here also happy to be
here greg good to see you again man it's
great to be back it's been 10 minutes
it's wild that you referred to liz
cheney as a neocon i love that
we are this is a huge win we are purging
our government and the republican party
of neocons rhinos and globalists we are
replacing them with people who are
america first and will actually fight
for the people who elected them and this
is a huge huge w on that and so i will
celebrate it very much
nice shirt dude yeah yeah yeah thank you
yeah and i am also here in the corner
thank you for coming back libby thank
you for coming back greg i'm excited to
talk about this tonight it's good news
all right so for that 28 of people in
wyoming who wanted liz cheney to win i
got good news for you cheney is
pondering a 2024 bid this is amazing
it's been like no it was not even a day
when she was comparing herself to
abraham lincoln and basically announced
she was running for president
i couldn't believe it was 20 minutes it
was 20 minutes 20 minutes she was like
the first thing she says abraham lincoln
lost many battles before going on to win
the most important he's like lost
election in the senate in congress
before going on to win the most
important it's like bro are you calling
yourself like are you comparing yourself
to abraham lincoln yeah and he's saying
you're going to run for president
there's gonna have to be a book deal
there's gonna have to be some you know
tv spots and special interviews and
things like that tucker nailed it
because he was like she's gonna she's
gonna start a foundation and write a
book called like democracy or something
oh gosh yeah
yeah i know and i will paraphrase
lincoln a little bit here and say that
by liz cheney losing by 40 points our
nation has gained a new birth of freedom
away from neocon war mongers yeah for
sure and so points man
but it just goes to show i think that
the point to be made here is that people
always like to say what she did was
brave when she came out and opposed
trump that that was somehow a brave
thing to do the least brave thing any
human being in washington dc can do
yeah the least brave thing any human
being in washington dc can do is claim
to be a republican and come out against
trump you will get showered with praise
from the media you will get you know
huge money you'll you're you'll if
you're like alyssa farah you'll get a sh
you'll get your own show you'll be
picked for the view
it's the easiest thing to do ever and so
she's not brave for what she's doing
she's really bitter that donald trump
turned the gop base against her family
dynasty and she was raised with
delusions of grandeur that she'd one day
be president and that's not possible
anymore she's bitter about it just like
hillary clinton in that respect but i
think a lot of it is that trump insulted
her dad
that's yeah i mean trump was the one of
the like the first major republican
candidate for president who came out
called out bush and cheney for the iraq
war that was amazing that was the only
that's the only reason liz cheney hates
him has nothing to do with january 6. it
was a convenient way for her to become a
martyr for her father's political legacy
what it all has to do is that trump
basically destroyed her family dynasty
and she'll never be president because of
it so we talked about how you know what
i think four is it four of the ten who
voted for impeachment republicans who
voted for impeachment retired yep maybe
more yeah
yeah there's more there's eight there's
only no no no no eight are out two one
but uh i think yeah i i might be more
than that because i think two uh uh lost
now how many lost so i'm trying to think
um
jamie herrera butler just lost to joe
kent so that's one yes
um
but it's it's it's a picture of a
retirement player yeah
he's got amanda he got jerry he did
everything the democrats wanted him to
do and they thanked him by
gerrymandering
imagine being as cocked as adam
kinzinger is oh what a loser
that guy is is like such spineless
establishment trash defending ray apps
it's like are you joking dude you could
come up with a better excuse well he
didn't actually go in the building shut
up you're better off saying nothing that
guy has no spine and so it's it's all so
much more sweet knowing that they
basically just booted him out so if
the january 6 committee continues into
the next congress
they're not going to have any concern
any republicans on the committee at all
it's not it's not going to it's not
going to continue
they're going to kill it it's not going
to continue when republicans win the
house because they now have the power to
make committees and suspend committees
so they would be able to just turn it
off i don't trust the republicans but i
am i i do think we're getting a lot of
those maga republicans in so maybe we'll
see something we are we are we've picked
up a lot of w's in these primaries like
i've i say to people all the time
primaries at this point are more
important than general elections
because like you can elect a republican
but if it's somebody who's going to be a
squish and not represent you the way you
should be what's the point but we've had
a lot of wins in this primary a lot of
great people have won who will actually
fight for the people who elected them
jack bazobic nailed it the other day
when he said that the january 6 hearings
are like a true crime show for all the
wine moms you know to watch and they're
getting ready for the next season or
whatever and he's right i mean they put
it on primetime tv
it's it is probably that demographic
who's listening to this going like oh
wow i knew the funny thing is as much as
they claim to hate donald trump a lot of
these people are the ones who are
probably writing him love letters once
he goes to prison assuming like these
are the kind of people that write love
letters to serial killers
so evil but i love you so much oh they
they secretly love donald trump because
donald trump is what gives them ratings
donald trump is what gives them page
views like i mean the ladies
oh yeah that's true i'm saying like
there are women who write love letters
to serial killers and like how they they
want to be with them and it's like that
dude like straight up killed a bunch of
people but they love it so like i'm
saying these these these true crime
women that are watching january 6 are
you know actually you know let me tell
you this there's a viral video of
someone asking three women what is a
woman
or like or i'm sorry it's it's a young
woman asking three other women and
someone had a good point about it i'm
not sure who it was it might have been
matt walsh and he said
they all know exactly what a woman is
but they're trying to reconcile what
they know it is with what they're
supposed to say right and so so that's
that's basically the point i'm getting
at people
will
say they hate trump say it's also evil
but they're so excited
watching this hearing about this
dangerous
large donald trump they're probably
getting all lusty
but how do you even like enjoy that like
i watched it for i watched the first one
for about 10 minutes and i felt like i
was at a party and some guy i hate came
up to me and started talking to me about
his 401k in excruciating detail that's
what fell i was like who who can cite
through this it's just you're listening
to adam kinzinger and benny thompson
just drone on for hours on end but
they're eating they're sitting there
eating popcorn they're like oh what's
going to happen next
it's it's it's you know they made that
podcast muller she wrote i think that's
what it was called oh during the russia
gate mueller she wrote
and it's it's just that it's it's like
true crime conspiracy nonsense for
suburban wine moms i guess that's liz
cheney's constituency
i mean probably yeah
i mean like i just gave him that season
they loved it what's hilarious about
that to me is the fact that the media
and the democrats new found fondness for
the chinese it's hilarious and it goes
to show there's there is a uniparty in
dc and they all secretly want the same
things and that's why they love liz
cheney so much it's not because she
spoke out against trump it's because
they all agree at the end of the day
it's not just that they'll agree they
want to maintain their power structure
and they don't want anybody to come in
who's going to disrupt that that's true
so that's why they that's why they stick
together but but she's just like not a
good person either like in one of my
favorite stories ever in the history of
politics is in 2014 she tried to primary
mike enzi senator from wyoming keep in
mind liz cheney in her formative years
only lived in wyoming for two years she
grew up in suburban virginia she went to
mclean high school this is like 10
minutes from where i live which is
hilarious and she's running for senate
wyoming and when she announced it was a
facebook post that was geotagged to
mclean virginia
and then in this race she came out and
publicly denounced her sister because
her sister is a lesbian and she came out
and publicly denounced her right race
recently that this was 2014. oh wow and
so like no matter what she denounced her
sister for being gay so she came out
against gay marriage and she has a
lesbian but yeah she did that and no
matter what your views on gay marriage
are if you're somebody who would come
out and denounce your own family in
order to win
a political in order to win at least
nothing like that is just that's
literally like that's not just not not
somebody who's a good person and like
somehow she found her ways chair of the
republican conference when she made it
to the house take a look at this this is
uh
liz cheney donate to the great task
is that a picture of abe lincoln it's a
picture of abe lincoln this is gross
what's their obsession with i understand
it's the party of lincoln and all that
but like the lincoln project they're
like abraham lincoln
donald trump what it's all this it's the
same stuff as like remaking game of
thrones and remaking the lord of the
rings and the remaking abe lincoln
trying cultural stagnation they're just
trying to stick with a brand that they
think works well like her whole her
whole reelection like she never had a
shot of winning like not in a million
years like this whole thing was just a
giant grift to raise money for an
eventual presidential campaign that will
also be a giant gift and that's now
she's obviously she's doing that and
that's it right there because i was
saying the other day like why wouldn't
she just retire and try and save as much
face as possible like all these other
guys and then i and now i realize like
she she she probably spent very little
she probably raised as much as she could
she went around saying democrats you've
got to support me we got to stop trump
collecting all this money and then she
probably didn't spend it she's probably
just like i don't need to use it i'm
going to lose anyway but i can keep it
for something else which is hilarious
because she raised big money like from
left wing like nine and like 90 percent
of it came from outside wyoming which is
hilarious i just i just absolutely love
the democrat twitter personalities who
are like the republican party died today
and it's like dude you don't you don't
like her and you're not in you're not
part of it anyway like you have no idea
but but it's just like
that
we expect that they wanted the party to
survive and do well no you hate
republicans you rag on them all day
every day you're only you're only
supporting her because she hates trump
if given the choice it's like kinzinger
he he he drops to his knees for the
democrats and then they're like
excellent and then they just they can
flap them into a bucket and yeah and
that's it's like actually like a movie
villain where the you know the villains
always just like kill their own henchmen
yes and there's a lesson to be had here
if you're a republican like i just
thought of another impeachment
republican that just got primaried peter
meyer from michigan who just lost to
john gibbs peter meyer in his primary he
you know he voted to impeach trump he
voted for gun control he voted for
ukraine aid he voted for all these
things that are incredibly unpopular
with the republican base
and what did the democrats do to thank
him they spent thousands of dollars
boosting his opponent in his own primary
and he ended up losing it and it just
goes to like if you are really going if
you you will never appease these people
you know you will never ever appease
this
does not matter you know who made the
right choice
jeff van drew that's true yeah when the
impeachment stuff was going on he was
like i'm not doing this and then he
switched and then he won he wants
primary landslides
it was like 80 80 points or whatever
he's he's a he was a former democrats a
moderate guy in south jersey backed
trump and ended up winning the primary
landslide yeah amazing and like people i
remember my mom was pissed about that
she's in she lives in jersey what she
doesn't like jeff andrew yeah she
doesn't make something
you see
this is the problem with american
politics and i'm not trying to be mean
to your mom but
if you would vote for a democrat and
then one thing changes i don't think we
should impeach trump so i'm i'm off the
democrat party and you're like well now
i don't like him like huh mm-hmm is that
the only thing you like been before
that's how it all works i mean the
democratic party at this point is the
party of hating trump they don't have
anything else they don't have any
policies that are effective that anybody
likes look at this whole fake inflation
reduction act it was full of
things that aren't going to help anybody
all of all they do is they boost chinese
industry in you know solar somebody's
got to do that well someone's got it it
may as well be us it may as well be our
tax dollars the big way that they're
going to pay for this bill and reduce
the deficit their whole plan is to
collect taxes from us
audits will happen middle and lower
income people will be audited but it's
not the main issue they're also just
raising our taxes they're they're
probably not doing that and this is the
game they're playing biden comes out and
he says we are not raising taxes on
anybody who makes less than four hundred
thousand dollars and we're not going to
be increasing audits on these people
that's the trick what's really gonna
happen anybody who runs a business knows
this
june you get a letter in the mail from
the irs and it says you owe us an
additional 1 593
send your check here there's no audit
there's no dispute an audit implies they
want to be fair with you and make sure
they're getting the numbers right they
don't take the thing oh i see they just
send you the bill
and this is this is why that's what they
do to me every year i get the my account
does the thing he says you're going to
get this much money back and then when i
get the money back i get way less and
the government says we actually took a
whole bunch more yep
and
i'm i'm i i know so many of you
listening this has happened to you that
they're they're they're me every year
the federal government and new york
state and the city and this is where i
see all the conservatives making a big
mistake when they're saying things like
oh they're gonna they're they're lying
they're gonna audit you it's like well
you know look maybe there probably will
be more audits washington post even said
it's gonna be middle-income people
there's more money to be gained out of
going after lower income people than
going after rich people yeah because
lower income people aren't going to do
anything they're just going to be like
oh they took a bunch of my money i still
have to get little johnny but the audits
implies the irs is being fair with you
to assume that you're going to get
audited is to assume the iris is like
we'd like more money from you but we're
going to give you a chance to prove you
don't owe it no you're saying it's just
another like everything additionally is
another rhetorical trick of course it's
the magic trick like the climate like
the climate thing the climate thing in
the bill is uh if you can afford to redo
your house you can get some credits by
putting solar on it that's if you have a
house and can afford to redo it
well the last few months of this
congress has taught me a valuable lesson
about the power you have when you have a
majority is you can essentially just
troll the ever living crap out of the
opposition into voting against something
that should be considered highly popular
but you you may you give it a popular
title but do things in the bill that
don't actually do what that title
implies and there have been so many they
do that all the time yeah but there have
been so many instances like it's just in
the last like couple months we had the
inflation reduction act which is not
going to reduce inflation anyway they
had the pudding baby formula on the
shelves act or something some crap like
that which i think the only thing that
bill did was give the fda more salaries
and expenditures the fda which caused
the baby formula shortage in the first
place but they were able to claim that
republicans voted against baby formula
they've done like so many things like
this the american rescue plan or
whatever are you feeling are you feeling
rescued right now i'm not you know it's
getting worse you know i just read i
read that um farmers are having to like
like destroy fields because the droughts
are so bad the plants aren't growing
anymore and they they can't they can't
make it work meanwhile the department of
agriculture decided to give out grants
and loans based on uh the race of
farmers yeah and this nobody talked
about this this was like over a year ago
and then courts struck it down finally
and was like oh actually you know what
that's discriminatory we have this crazy
thing called the civil rights act
you can't really deal with the situation
they were doing farmers uh so the
department of agriculture during covid
decided to give out a bunch of grants
and loans to farmers right to help
farmers out but the way that they
decided to do it was to prioritize
uh non-white farmers
and their reasoning was that this would
be a correction for past discrimination
done by the department of agriculture
and eventually you know a bunch of
farmers brought suit and said that's
discrimination and a court finally said
you know what you can't discriminate in
the present to try and correct
discrimination in the past but they're
doing this all over the country too not
just with farmers like there was just a
story that i saw the other day out of
minneapolis
which you know minneapolis has just
become a ridiculous place but the
minneapolis school board
just just the school district or the
school district they just they got a new
contract with their union that said in
the event that the school needs to be
downsized white teachers get fired
before minorities regardless is
regardless of seniority that's illegal
that is literally illegal
and you know what like there was a lot
of backlash because of course that's
remarkably discriminatory and racist
and the school district was like we're
going to do it anyway we think it's
correct and they have the same argument
which is that it corrects for past
discrimination
but we already have this precedent you
can't discriminate in the present to
correct discrimination in the past well
they're doing it they're doing it anyway
so this is the issue cultural
enforcement is always way more
way more powerful there are some
instances where you could discriminate
in the present like say there were two
warring parties and one warring party
killed all the fathers and then took the
children as slaves and now they own all
the land and you're like well we the
children now of the dead fathers are
like we want our land back they're like
sorry you can't discriminate against the
conquerors in the present because of
what you're like yo actually we can you
just killed my dad like i can definitely
discriminate against the guy that
murdered my father you're talking about
individuals
there are situations where you can
discriminate in the presence to to make
equal like equality of opportunity but i
don't think this is one of them right
right so discrimination in the most
literal sense
is not what we're actually talking about
discriminate means like when you choose
to go down a road that looks better
we're not talking about that if you're
talking about
a group of people that committed an act
of crime in real time and then we're
like hey we're going to stop that and
bring about justice yeah we have a civil
court for that yeah but it's like
criminal and civilization what happened
like 60 years ago and now they're all
kind of established all the conquerors
now own the land you're talking about
reparations talking about colonialism
and reparations yeah that's sort of a
different situation i don't think that's
what the department of agriculture was
trying to do because they weren't
talking about colonialism they were
talking about the department of
agriculture having previously perhaps
discriminated against or in favor of
white farmers there's also going to the
supreme court it's a little different
going to the supreme court in the next
term is going to be a case
involving harvard discriminating against
white and asian students there's a
lawsuit over that that's going to be and
harvard keeps oh i'm sorry and it's
gonna and and they're gonna and you know
what's hilarious about that is
the biden justice department the biden
administration who makes a whole they
brought bts to the white house to talk
about how we have to stop asian hate
they are literally defending harvard in
this case the doj filed an amicus brief
defending harvard's discriminatory uh
admissions practices against asians
harvard actually keeps saying that they
should discriminate against asian
students and they've also said um in
talking about why it's important for
them to discriminate they said if we're
not allowed to discriminate then how
will we be able to judge entrance essays
that talk about people's you know
difficulties being racially whatever
that's their argument that's not an
argument it's not a good argument no
it's total total trash that's the
they're just racists well that's the
thing about like this well harvard was
racist like they owned slaves yeah yeah
that was the thing though about like
when stop asian hate became like a huge
hashtag like as if out of nowhere racism
was happening against asians and it's
like the biggest source of racism
happening against asian americans is
happening on the admissions boards of
ivy league colleges well and high
schools
college high school literally literally
in all and in new york again in all
schools across the country but like the
focus was as if there's like white
supremacists out there who are all of a
sudden well discrimination there is a
disproportionately large amount of
asians at these schools and they can't
have that they don't they don't like the
fact that there's a community that for
some reason other uh uh prides
themselves on academia or something like
that well you know so what i the way to
try just the way i describe it to people
is if you're in favor of this then
here's what i want you to do
i want you to go to
some inner city kid who's asian and i
want you to be the one to explain to him
why he's not allowed to go to an ivy
league school because he looks too much
like those other people
well exactly the thing that it shows too
is that democrats don't think that
minorities are americans
they think that they are separate right
and need to be treated some separate and
different way
so they're the ones they're like
actually racist
bigotry
it's the whole thing yeah so they don't
think asian kids should get the same
opportunity as americans they don't
think that black kids should be held to
the same standards as americans and
they're the ones who are differentiating
and deciding that the people who are
getting everything are the white people
and that everybody else needs to be
treated some different and special way
and it's like meanwhile like anyone who
thinks reasonably realizes that all
these kids are obviously americans and
deserving of the same opportunity to
excel on their own marriage some of them
aren't america isn't that the thing is
that some are for kids that are foreign
coming to heart but once you're
i don't think that's it i think it's
mostly american asian-american kids
this also like hurts like this this type
of mindset also hurts them like i
remember there were these huge stories
that have gone around in the last year
about how like inner city schools in
baltimore and san francisco and in all
these other places
a lot of the kids like couldn't read
past like a fourth or fifth grade level
yet they were passing all of their
classes like they're they're
deliberately inflating their gpas you
know and that's like hurting them like
how does that help somebody when you
give when you when you deliberately
inflate their gpa because they're a
certain race even though they can't read
past like a level that they should be
able to well now that they have at
lowell high school in san francisco now
that they have uh made it more of a
lottery system so that you can get in
regardless of what your grades are
the grades across the board have gone
down like the school is not serving
students as well academically as it had
been they're also now rolling out a lot
of schools this equity
you know equity diversity grading system
which takes race into account in how
grades are calculated
geez
which is ridiculous
yeah it's crazy and that's and that's
why sp this is actually another control
enforcement i work i work with a pack
part of my my i didn't really introduce
what i do at the beginning of the at the
top of the show i did my toast till is
cheney being defeated
but what i might i work for a company
called x strategies and we work with a
lot of conservative organizations doing
consulting and digital work and one of
the people we work with is a school
board pack who are they're called the
1776 project pack shout out to my friend
ryan gordusky and they are a pack that
is seeking to replace school board
members with people who won't do any of
this crap and they've done a very good
job of it and it this it's important
that if you want to get this out of your
schools to vote in school board
elections because a lot of the ways that
these woke school board members get in
that leads to all of these policies is
the fact that very very few people know
when school board elections are
happening
at all and so next week in florida
there's an elect there's a primary
election next tuesday and
the the governor and the senators races
obviously desantis and marco rubio are
going to win their primaries by a mile
but
your school every county in florida has
a school board election on the ballot
and so
the fact that these big races that get
all the nash get all the national
attention may lead to some republicans
staying home you can't stay home because
your school board is on the ballot and
if a candidate gets over 50 in these
elections they automatically win
and so republicans if you if if you're
watching and you are a parent in florida
you need to vote in your school board
election next tuesday because that is
how because like a lot a lot of these
stories you're seeing about woke school
boards are happening in insanely red
areas and it's literally and the reason
they get in is because only the teacher
the people only the teachers unions know
that the school board elections are
happening and they get their people to
vote and all of the everyone there stays
home well it's been so interesting too
to see desantis going out and endorsing
candidates for the school board i've
never seen anyone endorse candidates for
school board before and now i get like
press releases about like who desantis
is endorsing
it's time to start paying attention yeah
these are important elections
these local elections impact your life a
lot more than national than these like
national elections do a school board
election has a direct impact on you in a
way that a congressional election does
not now it's important to vote in both
obviously but there is a distinction to
be made
let's uh let's let's jump to this very
important story about a
harassment campaign oh no by
conservatives against a poor
a children's hospital in boston
wbur says boston children's hospital
deluged in harassment campaign
heavens
what happened
boston children's hospitals become the
target of a harassment campaign based on
inaccurate information about its
transgender surgery program hospital
staff say the campaign includes
aggressive calls emails and death
threats from some providers it goes
without saying you shouldn't be sending
death threats nobody should
um however i often find that when it
comes to stories like this
concerned phone calls get called
harassment yeah that's correct so like
if you call me like i have some concerns
about what you're doing and they're like
oh i'm being harassed
quote we are deeply concerned by these
attacks on our clinicians and staff
fueled by misinformation and a lack of
understanding and respect for our
transgender community the hospital said
in a statement we are working with law
enforcement to protect our clinicians
staff patients families and the broader
boston children's community so this all
started when uh who was it was it
billboard chris
yes so chris posted a posted video from
boston children's hospital and he also
has evidence that talking about
hysterectomies well yeah
just in general he also has evidence
that they may be lying about the amount
of threats that they have because he
posted a team
he posted a tweet that i just pulled up
here and it says that he has a source
within boston children's hospital where
he got all this stuff from and he said
that that most of the people there don't
even know what is happening like he said
well that that's of course and so like
they well and and also that there have
not been ramped up security efforts at
the hospital at all
so let's
slow down
to explain what happened so this is a
video comes up showing boston's children
hospital putting it's a promotional
video explaining hysterectomies and
bilateral uverectomy or uv overrides
they actually had several videos up on
their site with very um
they're gone now with uh well-spoken
doctors talking about how important and
interesting these surgeries are smiling
cute music in the background
gender affirming gender affirming is
what they call it yeah lady doctors one
doctor was talking about the process of
a hysterectomy and saying that it's the
same for young adults as and for gender
affirming
treatment as it would be for anybody
else and talks about the full and
complete removal of
a woman's reproductive system no no the
bilateral uverectomy is differentiated
well she talks about the whole thing
she says that
you know she says that they remove the
uterus the fallopian tubes and they
could also remove the ovaries and the
cervix
so that's that's everything that's
taking it all that's taking it all out
at once uh you have another doctor
talking about how one way that you can
tell your pre-verbal child is trans is
if they play with
toys that are
stereotypically considered to be toys of
the opposite sex
how do they know that
like like
how does the child know that society has
deemed
this particular
toy of a human to be a male or female
toy like a girl playing with a doll
versus a boy playing with an action
figure they're just playing with people
they're just playing with people they
also that same doctor discusses in this
very short little clip a couple of
minutes long about how if your child
doesn't want to get a haircut
maybe they are trans if your child
doesn't want to sit to pee or does want
to sit to pee then perhaps uh your child
your pre-verbal child is trans any mom
will tell you
i mean my son still hates getting a
haircut yeah you know he's for sure a
boy like he's you guys have all met him
like he's clearly oh yeah yeah
so uh yeah so that's insane you also
have a doctor talking about uh
phalloplasties and how a phalloplasty is
done
um and that same doctor and that's one
that chris posted today that same doctor
because actually
we were all talking about this behind
the scenes and we saw them start to take
this stuff down and we were all me and
christina buttons who writes for the
post millennials we were all like record
it record it screen of course what's
happening what's happening now is you
had boston's children's hospital talking
about the gender affirming programs they
do
the media comes out all of a sudden
saying it's not true they're lies you
have to be at least 18. well but they
ignore the finer details and so what
ends up happening now is you have all of
these outlets trying to claim they don't
actually provide gender affirming
surgeries interestingly there's one
particular trans person person who
quoted vice
vice ran the story saying the far-right
target in the hospital saying that the
hospital says you should be at least 18.
and this trans person that's not true
yes came out and said no they it is
common to give 16 year olds gender
affirming surgery and then they
mentioned that they got it and that they
need to normalize it or whatever because
that's how you get it i mean i can i can
break this down for you a little bit too
i was working on this story last week
with christina buttons who wrote it and
did an amazing deep dive into that for
post-millennial and if you look at their
documentation prior to when they changed
it on the site
their forms for uh how to get how to go
about getting approved for
vaginoplasties
chest reconstruction
and um what's the other one
phalloplasties right they have it all
written down so they it says on their
forms uh
to get a phalloplasty you need to be
between 18 and 35
uh to get a vaginoplasty you need to be
between and you can look at it it's in
our story we have the screenshots it's a
to get a vaginoplasty you need to be 17
between 17 and 30. that would be the
removal of male sexual reproductive
organs right and and the reshaping of it
into something that appears like that of
the app so a 17 year old and it is
totally sterilized yes and it also says
that 15 year olds you have to be 15 in
order to get a chest reconstruction or a
double mastectomy of healthy breasts and
what's particularly interesting um is
that they change the language afterwards
the videos say exactly what they do
they also follow
these guidelines from wpa th w path that
say
and they say that they follow these
guidelines as do most most gender-y
clinic-y places they follow these
guidelines that also say that parents if
they if parents approve these procedures
they can be done at younger ages the
doctor who talks about the phalloplasty
or the vaginoplasty says that in some
cases it can be done younger as well so
yeah they're making this up so i have
here from
nih.gov
this is a report a single center case
series of gender affirming surgeries and
the evolution of specialty anesthesia
team
this is the journal of clinical medicine
mdpi
blah blah in there on the second page it
says in materials and methods boston
children's hospital is a pediatric
academic hospital in the united states
providing gender affirming surgery to
patients aged 15 years to 35 years of
age and they say including gender
affirming primary and multi-specialty
care involving inpatient and outpatient
care and they go on to mention other
things a bunch of other things but yeah
uh 15 year olds right getting sex change
surgeries but they also say additionally
and on the boston children's hospital
website they have these glowing profiles
they're promo profiles right of um
teens who have gone through their
program one of the teens their whole
family moved from texas in order to
access this these services and is on
puberty blockers and estrogen
and frequently has to go into the
hospital to get bone scans and things
like that because these are remarkably
dangerous drugs to take additionally
that child's parent is talking to
um the hospital about how to make sure
to harvest the reproductive material for
this child who will be fully sterilized
if they go through this procedure so
that they can have like their sperm when
they are grown up they have a
that person is
13. they also have a seventh grader
who is on puberty blockers and he's
really excited about being non-binary i
want to point out here from the
conversation the tavistock clinic was
shut down in the uk after review found
that they were actually causing serious
harm to children one of the cases was a
young female who was on puberty blockers
and developed advanced osteoporosis
where her bones became extremely brittle
and were cracking and uh that's the
danger of of these of these drugs and
it's and the reason i say that is
because the nhs shut down the program
now we can look at these other european
countries that are held up as like the
pinnacle of health care by the left they
talk about their scandinavia they're
ending it all they're saying it's bad
it's hurting kids now the uk is saying
yeah we can't do this well about time
the united states starts paying
attention where these other countries
are talking right but we have people who
are making far too much money off of
this if you look at some of the
reporting that jennifer billeck did have
done right she's done these deep dives
into capitalism she's done these deep
dives into the pharmaceutical industry
and found that the amount of money being
generated from giving these off-label
drugs to kids performing these surgeries
it's huge and now you have the bite
administration pressing for insurance
companies to cover this or else those
insurance companies are considered
discriminatory however
why is it that
it is discriminatory for insurance
companies to not cover breast
augmentation for men
but it's not discriminatory for
insurance companies to not cover breast
augmentation for women in fact if you
look at the supreme court ruling on
bostock which said that what's her name
amy schneider the man who was trans and
was going to the funeral home dressed um
in women's clothing right so the supreme
court said you can't fire
amy because amy if you fire amy for
wearing women's clothing you are
discriminating against amy on the basis
that amy is a man because a woman would
not be fired for wearing women's clothes
this was a supreme court right this was
the supreme court what basically this
that basically uh uh codified gender
identity as protected under right right
now to divorce civil rights exactly so
that's what bostock did now if you are
saying if you are requiring insurance
companies
to give boob jobs to men
on the basis that it's discriminate
discriminatory against their gender
identity to not fund that that's what
they're doing this is what the
bi-administration has instructed
medicaid to do under hhs
huh yes
i wrote about this for human events yeah
so
what's interesting is
is it not discriminatory
to tell a woman that she cannot affirm
her female gender identity free boob
jobs free boob jobs for men though not
for women not for women i think that's
discriminatory because you're only
you're discriminating against a woman's
gender identity by not letting her get
boob jobs first
you can put it simply you can't provide
to one sex
so i think medicaid really needs to step
it up and start providing plastics boob
jobs for women for free additionally
most guys in this country
yeah sex work is work y'all right so
don't you think that underprivileged
women should have the opportunity to
further their careers in sex work
by getting free boob jobs under medicaid
boobs to be good at sex let's just get
that on the table i'm i'm just in all of
the fact that i'm just saying i'm in awe
don't you think i mean all of the fact
that we're even like having this
conversation like what the hell
the hell are we doing this conversation
literally
ever since the large hadron collider
fired up in 2016. this is the our
universe has been we're imploding are we
even talking about men getting boob jobs
like what they want this is like because
they don't want to be men and they they
just they maybe they just want to stay
home and play with them you're speaking
my mind greg like i'm like why
something's a hard one to go like but i
think people need to hear it they need
to listen
look
we'll we'll keep it to the basics of the
law and i think the challenge with the
law is you can't have moral logic
in the law otherwise you will get things
you don't want so
i mentioned this a couple times but i'll
break it down this way
the left says
we want gender identity to be protected
the law then says okay that has to be
defined in such a way that anyone can
understand it so in new york they say
gender identity is self-expression but
self-expression is so broad it now
starts to encompass literally anything
and now they actually say that any
gender that you come up with or clothes
you wear
so the the what ends up happening is
when you say
we shouldn't allow the government to you
know pay for plastic surgery or whatever
you get the question of well what about
this person needs gender affirming care
to save their life okay we'll allow that
okay well what about a woman who also
has depressive is depressed for having
small breasts she needs it for the exact
same reason she's depressed she's having
suicidal ideation and believes talk to
her therapist that breast implants would
uh alleviate the depression body
dysmorphia
then you based on the the moral logic or
the it's we have to provide it to
everybody right well now i don't think
well actually i should say i think the
left probably would be on board with
that but this is this is where it gets
difficult for you know where we are if
you would argue that in florida parents
have the final say in what medical
treatments their kids get and what their
kids learn that includes a parent
choosing to give their kid a sex change
operation so if you if you don't want
the government mandating vaccines then
then i think it's just you to come out
and say it's not about moral logic and
consistency in the law it's about
upholding your values and your values
will say the government should stop one
thing but should not stop the other
based on your personal beliefs so do you
think parents should be allowed to
amputate their children's legs
well i'm not saying one way or the other
what i'm saying like should that be
legal but this is my point right hell
you think unless there's a threat to the
kid's life so why should they be allowed
to amputate their i think the answer is
clearly yes dicks like don't you think
it's
should a parent be allowed to bring
their kid to the doctor get their legs
amputated yes absolutely healthy legs
we're gonna say healthy i'm staying
healthy that's the caveat right so
here's the issue if a kid has got a mrsa
or gangrene or something or or a serious
catastrophic injury and the doctor says
i believe the leg should be amputated
how does the government if they're
seeking to intervene to prevent healthy
amputations determine fast enough in
this circumstance this is the challenge
of hard moral logic in the law we have
to recognize it's about values and not
about saying government should or
shouldn't so if a parent goes to the
doctor the doctor says if we don't cut
this leg off the kid's gonna get a blood
infection and die and then the
government goes that leg looks fine to
me you're amputating your kid's healthy
leg well now we go back to the christian
scientists remember who refused medical
treatment across the board and i think
ended up getting sued for that right
what doesn't the supreme court make a
decision on christian scientists who
don't want to bring
medical treatment for their kids well
it's it's a big it's a big challenge
this was like when i was a kid they were
talking about this but i think there's
like a distinction to be made about you
know if you're losing the like example
of a parent saying that they just want
to amputate their their kid's leg for
shits and gigs but no one is saying that
when it comes to when it comes to gender
affirmation the parents are saying i'm
concerned my kid will kill themselves
because they've become depressed and
they're having suicidal ideation okay
but now a lot of these institutions are
just speeding these kids through as we
learn from helena kirschner and many
other de-transitioners they walk in and
there's like an hour consultation before
they're given powerful drugs so the
issue is when it comes to should parents
should parents have final say you run
into a challenge of saying i strict i
stick to the strict uh reality of law no
you don't you would say no you can't
amputate the genitals of this child
that's wrong government should stop you
however in other circumstances you want
the parents to have total discretion
see my view is parents can have
discretion but i would like to ban
them from surgically mutilating the
bodies of their children i don't think i
can be a hypocrite for saying that i
want government to come in and say you
are not allowed to do this this is evil
this is hurting children you're also not
allowed to beat your children yeah like
this is my fault
like there have been no long-term
studies about what the effects of these
drugs do to kids over time like there
have been no long-term studies this is
the point i'm making you cannot make the
argument that parents should have final
say if you believe there are
circumstances where they should not
it's it's so so we went through this
with the parental rights and education
bill where everyone said parents have a
right to determine what their kids are
learning and i say i agree with that and
there are there are circumstances we had
someone on recently
we were talking about
if parents don't want to give their kid
you know cancer treatment should the
government intervene take their kids
away and they said yes the government
absolutely should and i'm like no way i
completely opposed bethany mandela
that's christian that's the i watch that
episode that's the uh i don't think
that's christian scientist knows
everything and i think there's there's
very difficult questions in what's right
for your children and the last thing i
want is for the government to come in
and say we're injecting your child
against your will with something you
know
not every parent is a doctor not every
you know most parents are not doctors
considering and so there's a real
challenge of when you let the government
come in and decide what medical
treatments you have to get yeah there is
they're gonna get taller surgery they're
gonna get taller surgery but they
already do that like they do that with
like there are vaccines that you have to
get in order to send a child to public
school like they're doing that but there
are exemptions to those i'm pretty sure
and i still i i
you know
there there are tough questions about
the government coming and saying because
you did not do this we're taking your
children away and well you don't have to
do it but you can't come to our place if
you didn't well there's a very good
there's a polio outbreak in new york
right now because
people didn't get their kids vaccinated
is that why though yes i mean this is
new york
new york new york is full of is full of
anti-vaxxers well no it's happening
mostly i think isn't it
isn't it happening mostly in the
orthodox jews yeah it's happening mostly
in rockland county in the uh because
because orthodox jews don't don't
believe in any of that because i called
my kid's doctor i was like so polio
what's the deal what are we doing now
and he was like uh it's unvaccinated
that's what it is and i was like oh
that's still i'm gonna with a grain of
salt i don't know i don't know why
people are getting polio sometimes
diseases come out they tell you it's for
one reason turns out it's for another
reason
oh interesting yeah but i just think
like just when it comes to you know
mutilation of a healthy child's bodies
who have gender dysphoria and need help
that doesn't involve going through a sex
change operation when you're 13 or 14
years old i don't see why i don't see
why you can take the position of parents
rights while also saying this should be
illegal because this is wrong and it's
hurting people and it's causing
irreversible damage to children every
day i think if if you do that to your
children you are abusing your children
and child abuse is what we consider to
be legal or illegal i've got uh i went
to an antique store and they had 340
life magazines from like 1940 to 1970.
amazing i bought them all and we're
going to put together like a reading
area so we can basically like what i
want to do is i want to like uh
sort them that's the word sort them all
by date and then do a kind of like
breakdown of stories at the time how
they were reported versus what we know
now because we have like vietnam stuff
but i bring this up because thalidomide
yeah i was just gonna is one of the
magazines that i have oh when it was
great thalidomide
great mother's anti-nausea medicine
you're pregnant take this and then the
kids had no arms right you're like they
were all weird yeah they're like their
arms yeah they had just like hands on
their shoulders yeah and it was like was
it for morning sickness or whatever it
was for morning sickness yeah now what i
don't want
here's here's the challenge when when a
new treatment comes out there's a per
there's a person have a right to try it
does it like if a drug comes out and
says this will treat your morning
sickness whenever right to take it oh
yeah trump trump signed right to try
into law no no but that's that's when
you're dying i'm talking about an
anti-nausea medicine comes out women
will take it and then all of a sudden a
few years later we're like whoopsie why
don't you think that there should be a
controls process but but there is
remember remember that was that birth
control that got recalled i don't know
the name whatever orthotricyclin they
all get recalled at some point there was
some commercial that was really popular
and like a year later they were like
gardasil i don't know i don't know
gardasil is the hpv vaccine yeah they
they they recalled it or whatever the
the issue is
if there's something being sold and
there's some treatment right so like um
you know joe rogan talks about nad and
stuff
and uh luke was on the show talking
about stem cell therapy where they give
you an iv and flood your body with stem
cells to repair damage and it's like
what's the long-term effects of that
because we've not been doing that for a
long time should people have a right to
try that if they want there's
they say it's safe they say it can be
used to treat cancer my point is you
could get a treatment and then it turns
out it's really really bad you know like
like thalidomide these women were like
hey this medicine's gonna make me not
feel sick and then their kids had no
arms like totally crazy stuff
and then once they found out they're
like we got to stop doing that
so you know ultimately what it comes
down to is
i don't think the government should
mandate and then there are questions
about what the limits we set are when
the government can mandate it's not as
simple as to say
the government can or can't it's a
simple to say we have values and we've
determined in some areas we won't allow
it in some areas we will
i'm i mean yeah like i just take the
position that child abuse is illegal
like i consider this child abuse if you
are doing this to your kid who has
gender dysphoria because like why do a
lot of parents like tran put their
child's their children through this is
it because they really care about them
or are they just like really woke and
want to be cool in front of their
friends i think it varies i think i
think it varies a lot too but like it is
still child abuse to do this and child
abuse is illegal like we don't allow
parents to abuse their children because
because that's parents rights like that
would be illegal they would be arrested
for that of my a good friend of mine her
daughter is going through this now um
and she was convinced to
push her daughter into this direction
because
um the psychologist said that her
daughter was going to kill herself okay
but like we're seeing like that that
suicide rates are up a lot with people
who do go through this as well this was
about six years ago so
that's where they are they're dealing
with this now let's jump to the story
speaking of child abuse
hunter biden attributes his penis
obsession to body dysmorphia this is
what i was telling you about before yeah
i just i just want to say i think i
think i think hunter biden was abused by
joe for sure
hands down there is something right
there's something weird there's
something insanely messed up about that
family yeah let me tell ya
so uh hunter biden said his obsession
with naked selfies was the result of
body dysmorphia according to a rambling
screed found in the notes of his hard
drive i love to be reassured that my
i'm not reading this
i think you have to all right you gotta
do it you gotta do it all right
strap in everybody here we go
yeah buy the ticket take the ride i love
to be reassured that my nine inch very
big penis was actually big it may sound
funny to you but it's body dysmorphia i
know my penis is almost twice the size
of an average man's penis the first son
wrote on july 12 2018 the note was found
in the hard drive of a laptop biden left
at the delaware i think this dude was
heavily abused by who's he writing the
note to himself his diary entry or to
his dad because they remember when he
sent adult materials to his dad he's i i
missed that yeah it was a link to
pornhub wow
and it was sent it was like a text by
just two dad
yikes i think come on when you see
something like that you're like this guy
was abusing his kids well what's what
what i would never send porn to mike one
of the most like
[Laughter]
that's a hot that now that's that is a
controversial take right there joe well
you say that and hunter biden is
watching oh well so
so
one of the most play wordle yeah it's
not the same
one of the most i think the most
ridiculous things that has had like the
most ridiculous stories that has come
out in the joe biden era
it has to do with with the ashley biden
diary and project veritas they had this
diary
where ashley biden wrote in it that joe
biden
said like abused her sexually
and in other words but and like overtly
and seriously yeah oh yeah like she said
she would say that he would take like
inappropriate showers with it said all
of these nasty things i don't know i'm
sorry but i saw the shower thing but
what was beyond that i didn't i i can't
remember off the top my head but it had
to be very like but it had like some
nasty it had nasty things in it and
like they had this diary the new york
times confirmed that this diary was real
and nobody talks about it instead
project veritas journalists get raided
by the fbi over it oh yeah and that
that's then like there is something
seriously seriously wrong about the bind
family and the media doesn't have videos
of joe biden sniffing little girls like
it's it's right in front of your face
it's been in front of everyone's face
for a long time and so it's not
far-fetched to say that he probably
abused hunter
like hunter is a messed up guy yeah like
everything he's writing about the things
he does the drugs i won't say probably
it's likely i mean i wouldn't be
surprised
yeah it was abused i don't know who did
it it could have been joe could have
been joe's brother it could have been a
friend of the family a lot of times it's
a friend of the family here's the thing
though here's the thing about here's the
thing that like counters the argument
that joe who did it was that bo biden
was like a very upstanding human he was
the good son he was like an upstanding
human being he was you know an iraq war
veteran he was an attorney general he
was not messed up in the same way that
hunter biden was well he was supposed to
be the one to take everything over he
was supposed to be the the senator and
the
president and everything like that so i
think everyone's just disappointed that
hunter biden the body man is the one
that's stuck around yeah
that's harsh that's harsh hunter if you
hear this man you got this bro listen
here's the thing i don't i honestly i
feel kind of bad for these guys for
ashley biden and for hunter biden and i
think it's a shame that they never had
the opportunity opportunity to do
anything in their own right really
um but they're treated badly i mean joe
biden treats hunter biden really badly
i've never seen the two interact no but
i mean everything he says about him
constantly saying you know this is the
smartest guy ever met and then you read
laptop from hell and he's totally
trashing him to his face behind the
scenes literally calling him a pedophile
yeah like horrible stuff you know it's
like he says one thing about his son in
public and everybody knows that he's
saying this other stuff behind the
scenes that would make me feel so
demoralized yeah what did he do
peter peto peter
and like it's like it's sad but at the
same time it's a it's a fair game to
attack it it's fair it's fair game for
us to go after it because like imagine
if this was the trump family but but i'm
not going after anything i'm pointing it
out i mean this is the first son who
calls his dad a child yeah well i'm
saying like the media comes back and
says you're attacking his family why
would you attack his family and it's
like okay imagine this was the trump
family you'd be doing it like they could
have asked for course he'd have his door
kicked down by the fbi raid and purple
you know i i i have the things on her
body i did i i ignore the whinging of
the democratic press i i try not to
ignore when they're lying out right we
can call it their lies but there's a ton
of these democrat activists who are like
and i'm just like i don't care dude you
know them coming out and being like
don't attack the first family it's like
a bunch of french people young at me in
french i'm like i don't know what what
you're saying i don't care what you're
saying it's irrelevant
now if they're coming out and they're
writing fake stories like the boston
children's hospital thing if you're
trying to you know obfuscate what's
really going on you got to call that out
that's like manipulation and lies with
hunter biden
know dude this guy his laptop is
confirmed by multiple outlets the emails
are confirmed even the new york times
said it and a year and a half after the
fact oh and the media and and and big
tech suppressed the information well
yeah that's what they do like if you
look at this right now i just got sent
this
uh libs of tiktok facebook account was
just suspended for no reason at all no
reason at all and the big tech companies
are backing all of this yeah and like
their reaction to you know the boston
children's hospital story has and
like their reactions to a lot of similar
stories when it comes to
when it comes to the transgender issue
is literally insane like my friend jamie
michelle who runs an organization called
gays against groomers which is just like
you know they're they're kind of just a
media thing where a bunch of where
they're all gay and trans and they talk
about how they talk against like sex
changes for kids and they they speak out
against groomers and they had their
twitter account suspended today and
they've been you know shadow band was
instagram was it reinstated it was
reinstated like right before the show
yeah this rain stated but i wonder if uh
lips of tick tock will have any recourse
like that with facebook but they have
they're going after libs of tiktok hard
for this too like there have been there
i've seen so many you know woke
journalists who have been saying why
hasn't twitter suspended libs have take
out tick tock yet for posting things
that this hospital is posting on their
youtube channel you know what i was
thinking um we talked about this before
that this issue didn't exist prior to
the advent of widespread hormonal uh
treatments or the isolation of the
hormones in general so you know i've
talked to some people like where where
was this issue 100 years ago well there
was no isolated hormone i think they did
like serotonin first so you couldn't
take
any anything to to change your body well
and then they turn it turned out that
the ssris are bogus anyway well so the
argument was that uh
trans people have always existed but
they were just extremely depressed
uncomfortable in their bodies and it
wasn't a public issue because no one
knew with the advent of hormonal
therapies these people were now having
access and this issue emerges there's
also and i wanted i just wanted to point
out
what that means if if the reason the
issue exists is because the medical
technology has emerged to allow it to
exist in this form then once we get to
like dna splicing viruses there's going
to be people who are like i want to be a
cat yeah and they're going to start
taking pills that start cutting their
dna
people who want to do that like you see
that there's people who get like a full
body
modification to be cat looking or to be
like like who's that the
i don't know i'm not comic book person
but there's the guy who got fully
changed to be like the red death guy
yeah and like a red skull yeah and his
nose totally done if you look it up wow
there he is or there's the lady the lady
who became looking exactly like a barbie
doll with the exact barbie
um yeah it's it's proportions including
like the crazy eye thing and hair
extensions and the boobs and the whole
thing i mean people can use this
medical frankenstein technology to do
whatever they want and the doctors who
go along with it
have really found their sweet spot with
the whole trans thing because they can
do it without having to feel bad about
performing medical experiments on people
i think there's all there is also i
think a major major cultural aspect to
it as well because like if you look at
you know there are studies about with
the percentage of people in specific
generations that identify as lgbt and in
in like the younger generations it's at
like 15 20 percent like 30 and it's like
it's like it's grown from like two
percent in the silent generation to like
20 today like did that happen
i don't think that happened by accident
i think i'm just trying to bring up that
like
where this goes from here
is you know not not to rehash things
that we've we talked about the previous
segment something different and that is
we're we're going to develop new
technologies you know people like hunter
biden who's got dysmorphia or whatever
oh he's going to take a pill that's
going to you know
enlarge himself things like that people
are going to do it like crazy people are
going to start doing designer gene
therapies on their kids so like
we we've talked about i mean you i
assume you guys have seen gattaca
we're going to get to the point where
it's just like
why have your kid with bad eyes why have
your kid have bad hair why have your kid
with with your kid should be six foot
five and then we're gonna just
homogenize everybody well and then if
your parents can't afford to have you be
recreated as some extra smart person
you're just going to be
way down below everybody else
taxpayers to pay for it and make it
mandatory or like optionally that's what
they're doing with the with the
surgeries on or what biden's trying to
do is make the make it tax funded yes
that's right
and that's why and desantis was like no
medicaid will not be funding this in
florida and in canada like canada a lot
i don't know if this is a federal law in
canada but a lot of canadian provinces
have laws where if you don't respect
your child's identity the state can take
your child away from that is that is
federal and part of that has to do with
the conversion therapy ban that was put
into law by the trudeau liberals so
basically they redefined conversion
therapy and biden has taken a cue from
you know pretty boy justin up there um
and what they've done is they've said if
you do not affirm your child's identity
if you in fact say hey daughter you're
actually my daughter then that is
conversion therapy and that is illegal
and and that happened in texas too like
remember that story in texas jeffrey
younger jeffrey younger he was a kid he
was a kid who
in
a court ruled that his father was like
no longer like he didn't younger was the
dad yeah yeah the jeffrey he got custody
of his son taken away from him because
he wouldn't affirm his identity as a as
a girl meanwhile he had evidence that
his son was being like i'd rather wear
boy clothes yeah it was all his his mom
just like being totally being totally
insane let's jump to this other very
contentious social issue ooh i saw this
on rodeo joe rogan references his 14
year old daughter
and uh
you know pro-choice in a heated debate
about abortion he said you know you're
not going to force a 14 year old who's
been raped to carry the rapist's baby i
thought it was interesting because he
had on seth dillon and they both made
their points they it was well well
stated on both sides i think seth dylan
made some interesting points let's read
this so we'll talk about joe rogan
clashed with the conservative
commentator during a heated debate about
abortion is is seth dillon as a
commentator is it why what are just
comments i thought he was actually
he's the ceo of the babylon but i think
i mean
even bringing up his uh but he but he
like does political commentary on
twitter the polarizing podcaster he's
polarizing he's the most popular
previously stated he's 100 for a woman's
right to choose full stop no joking
joking no joe rogan no joking joking
that's it he's joking from now on uh
wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong i i
i will i will bet 100
okay no a gentleman's bet i never liked
putting money a gentleman's vet good sir
joe rogan that if i sat down with him
and we had a conversation he would
recant that statement oh for sure
outright
so we'll talk about it so uh he says
there are women who have been raped who
should not have to effing carry some
rapists baby rogan exclaimed there's
women who have been assaulted before the
age of 14.
dylan the founder of uh he's not the
founder of babylon he's the ceo adam
adam ford's the foundation right right
right right right right right right
right there wrong new york post fact
check
he said there are people who have been
born of rape and are alive right now and
are pro-life they go around speaking and
say i had a right to live they will go
around making a case and they were born
of rape
so uh i actually i i totally understand
what seth seth dylan is is saying i do
agree with joe in this capacity about
for one a 14 year old i i think that's
not a viable pregnancy like way too
young to be able to to uh carry a baby i
mean it's
that's the age where the doctor's gonna
make a decision but i i fall on the the
more libertarian side of the government
can't force someone who was already
forced to carry a baby in their body
that's a difference though the reason i
say joe rogan would recant that
statement if i talk to him i guarantee
you joe rogan is not in favor of uh
abortion at nine months for elective
reasons i i hate this debate so much and
the reason i hate it is because
it's like not it's not due to the fact
that i don't want to talk about it it's
the fact that abortions because of a
rape are exceedingly rare in comparison
to what most abortions are right it's a
way for the left to kind of get away
from talking about what abortion
actually is where they just say oh
there's a if a 14 year old was raped you
wouldn't you would support her carrying
a rapist baby and it's like that is not
even that is a significant hold on it's
really really simple it's really simple
when the left says that your the
response to joe rogan is you know what
joe i'm gonna give you that one uh so
then do you think that all other
instances where it's not would that be
okay to ban well so if you want to talk
about banning the 93 percent of elective
abortions with no reason given or
whatever then i agree with you okay rape
excluded women can get abortion can get
abortions if they've been raped and now
you agree to ban 93 of abortions well so
seth did i watched i watched this
episode yesterday in full and seth did
that because they started talking about
the case in nebraska there was this big
case in nebraska recently that the media
lied through their teeth about there was
there was this mother and she had a 17
year old daughter who was 23 weeks
pregnant so six months the facebook yes
so so this this is a fully formed baby
this and it's 23 weeks nebraska had a 20
week abortion man this woman gave her
daughter abortion pills and they still
born to the baby at their house they
then took it and they burned and buried
the body and the police got hold of this
because of a tip from somebody and so
they subpoenaed their facebook dm or not
subpoenaed they uh
they got a search warrant for their
facebook dms because they talked they
had talked about us like the daughter
was like i can't wait to get this effing
thing out of me and they're under
they're now being charged with multiple
felonies for this but the media lied
about it because they said facebook
turned over dms to the police like the
headlines from so many media outlets
were literally facebook turns over dms
to the police to prosecute teenager for
having an abortion without mentioning
the fact that they did this at home for
the fully formed baby that they burned
and buried in their in somewhere so uh
absolutely psychotic and not surprised
the media lied seth brought that up to
joe yeah so they started talking about
and joe was obviously against that like
he said like that's ridiculous and and
everything and that's the thing like if
when joe says you know he previously is
100 for a woman's right to choose he's
not 100 for women's rights no i think
that's out of context that statement
because it's that i don't think that's
not something he would say with no
pretext he was probably saying that in
reference to something maybe maybe i
didn't see the show do you remember greg
when he said that did he come off as
saying no he did say he said well no he
said he's like in favor fair point he
said quote it gets weird when the baby
gets like six months old i know that
some states have late from abortion and
sometimes you need one for medical
reasons right the woman could die if she
gives birth like it's a decision that
people have to make i am 100 for a
woman's right to choose but as a human
being just a person observing things
there's a big difference between a
little clump of cells and a fetus with
the eyeball and the beating heart funny
for anybody to pretend there's not okay
so actually there's there's a beating
joke
part of it nice job newsweek you screwed
that one up he says where do you draw uh
his guess is where did you on the line
says right where do you draw the line
that's the question it's what i call a
human issue it's a very complicated
issue it's so fraught with emotion it's
so political but that question is
something the left cannot answer they
cannot answer where they draw the line
and that's why they don't that's why
that that bill in congress they're like
well yeah so that's why they constantly
bring up things like
would you would you let that 10 year old
carry her rapist like the story we saw
in ohio of the 10 year old who
apparently who got raped by i called
that i called that a movie
[Music]
it ended up not being a hoax that a 10
year old child was impregnated by rape
but it ended up being the fact that it
was her mother's boyfriend who was
illegal no no it was a hoax so uh the
reason i say that is because obviously
it did happen obviously there was a
pregnancy obviously there was a crime
committed but
when you look at the statements from the
local government and it was in ohio
right yeah and they said she could have
she could have gotten the treatment but
they did not do it they went somewhere
else instead so what i'm saying is it is
a hoax in the sense that they drummed up
a big political story for political play
without the full context exactly what
about the 16 year old girl in florida
what about the 16 year old girl in
florida who's an orphan she has no
parents she's pregnant she's 10 weeks
pregnant
um oh yeah we have that story actually
the judge ruled she's not mature enough
to have an abortion the judge ruled that
she's not mature enough to have an
abortion that she's not allowed to make
the decision for herself she is within
the
uh timeline where an abortion would be
permissible under florida law really
they're not allowing it and they're not
allowing it because um a parent or
guardian would have to make that
decision she doesn't have any of that
well then she's the she's the guy she's
the guardian but she's not the legal
guardian the state is the legal guardian
of this girl right that's annoying i
think this is crazy i think this is
crazy yeah i mean she's within the the
legal limits of the of the law
right
well they're not allowed
human life should not be should not be
taken
yeah i do think that there should be
exceptions for rape and incest for sure
and i do think that there should be
limits but this isn't this isn't rape is
this whole like no this this case is not
rape but i i do think that there should
be you know i don't think nine months
obviously and i do think that it should
be very tight to near conception
um well so this is this 16 year old and
i don't think anyone should do it but
like i also think there should be is
this 16 was a 16 year old uh it wasn't
statutory rape or anything like that it
was like no she's she was with a fella
and she said he's not capable of helping
out he's not going to be a dad he's like
not around and what's the justification
for why she should be able to get an
abortion is 16. it's within the it's
within the laws of the state of florida
florida florida has a 15 week that's
right so she's under the time limit
wow that's crazy
yeah i don't like it man the way i see
it is like if a woman feels the need to
terminate a pregnancy like she's been
let down by society let down by her
family not entirely well that's that's
what i like that's what i see like i i
see i see it as a problem when women
feel like when a woman feels like there
is no way out there's something that
nobody talks about right there's
something that nobody talks about that i
have experienced among my friend group
over the past you know however old i am
um and that joe biden has certainly
picked up on they have a new plan
to promote their abortion message by
targeting men and telling men like hey
be pro-abortion right
i have known so many women
married unmarried with a guy who have
been coerced into getting an abortion
you know i i knew one woman who her
husband just didn't want to have kids
and was like if you don't abort these
babies this baby i'm gonna leave you
that happened over and over in that
marriage i have another friend it was
before she got married
all she has to do is say
no if i have it you can't
sure
sure there's always the thing you can
say right well i mean the issue is
there's always the other thing that you
can come up with when a woman gets
however she has legal control in courts
and understands finances she felt very
coerced and forced into getting this
abortion that's that's what ended up
happening whether you think she should
have felt that way or not that's how she
felt and i've known that to happen to
many other women where the reason they
get the abortion is either
to keep the man or you know to do what
they're told or to not get beat or
whatever it is
men do coerce women to getting abortions
that happens and we have to deal with
that as well it's not just the woman
being like well you know i think i want
to do this today men are culpable in
this as well and nobody talks about like
the depression and other like you know
things like that that can happen to
women after they have an abortion and
like it's disgusting and that's
disgusting that it happens but this is
something that the biden administration
has said out loud like kamala harris in
did like a round table with a bunch of
abort like abortion activists and she
was talking about like what are you
going to tell you are you going to tell
your son that when if they get a girl
pregnant that like she was saying this
could affect you because your son is now
having a baby and it's like okay we're
going to teach men that they're not
responsible for their actions i had the
same exact thought with that and i've
actually had the conversation with my
son who's 12 i've been like listen if
something happens and
you know god forbid this happens and
someone gets pregnant mommy is here
i have a stable home mommy is here i'll
be happy to be the grandma
like it you know that's right i know
that sounds ridiculous like i just hate
it like i just want to put that out
there
like we're just a culture that doesn't
value life or personal responsibility
that comes with it and i think that
needs to change that's
look i i our culture is decaying and
collapsing i think cultural enforcement
is everything the laws are meaningless
when your culture won't uphold the law
so
everything we're talking about is really
just rooted in
like american values and and culture has
just eroded the point where you have
one faction which is most of the
democrat voters the anti-trump people
with no moral framework whatsoever and
then you have the traditional american
moral framework the democrats have
become so insane when it comes to
abortion like they're literally nuts
like they they tried to pass a bill well
they did pass a bill in the in the
in the house
that would have nullified every state
pro-life law across america and it would
have allowed for abortion at any time
for any reason at all and i think the
median american voter does not support
that by by polling data like the median
amer the median voter in america
supports abortion within like you know a
few certain weeks but democrats have
become so nuts on this issue that
they've made it like they think the
overturning of roe v wade was going to
be their saving grace in this midterm
and i don't think that because i don't
because the american people are not as
insane on abortion as the institution
and like abortion for no limits for no
reason at all repealing the high demand
amendment taxpayer funding that's that's
that is in the democratic party
i mean the thing is the democrats want
us to kill our babies and they want to
they want us to sterilize our children
they're sterilizing their children and
they're getting abortions so the future
will be christian conservative
okay
so that's always worked out well in the
past but i'm not saying it's i'm not
saying it's good or bad i'm saying
that's the reality of
one political group removing their
children's ability to reproduce and then
literally removing their children and
they're trying to remove our children's
arizona just past school choice right
that was a big thing corey d'angelos was
tweeting about so yeah this if
conservatives went on this front it's
it's the end of the leftist ideology
yeah because there'll be there'll be no
uh no way to force us to change but but
let me jump to this story here from
lottery with crowder.com
uh crowder's been suspended guys uh so
uh we don't know why crowder doesn't
know exactly why it was his interview
with carrie lake we've had her on the
show several times we've not had these
issues we've talked about a whole lot
crowder team crowder writes ladies and
gentlemen the orwellian centers at
youtube are at it again this time
they've chosen to not only target louder
with crowder but to silence republican
republican gubernatorial candidate
carrie lake our interview with the
arizona gubernatorial candidate has been
removed from youtube over their alleged
misinformation policy
crowder is unable to live stream on
youtube for the next two weeks what
specifically ran a file of the policy
only youtube knows
but our lawyer william richmond will be
getting answers we'll share with you on
the show thursday august 18th there will
be a show and this is really important
guys uh if if you guys are uh you know
typically tune in to crowder
now you know make sure you tell
everybody what happened because
they're having shows i'm assuming
they're gonna be putting them up on
rumble rumble.com
stevencrowder and uh
welcome to midterms everybody we this is
good we knew this was gonna get crazy
who did we have on we just told us i was
gonna get really crazy
was it naomi wolfe yeah i think it was
naomi she was like it's gonna get yeah
that was a good episode too that's gonna
get crazy
yeah you think there's suspending
crowder it they're gonna they're gonna
do everything they can to try and
diminish the voice of those who oppose
the establishment they don't like that
liz cheney lost they're going after alex
jones they're trying to indict donald
trump they just took crowder down for
two weeks off youtube
that matters
real quick you know what you know why
youtube matters 95 of gen z say says
they use youtube it is the pre is the
dominant platform for the younger
generation that's right this is where
people need to be to be reaching the
younger generation being forced on a
rumble rumble's great i like rumble but
it's not where the younger generation is
yeah this is what uh jordan peterson was
saying years ago when he was asked why
he was going on youtube and doing videos
instead of writing articles or something
and he was like i wanted to reach the
most people so that's why i went on
youtube do you think they're going to
indict trump i think they are absolutely
they really are absolutely going to they
are going to have to now i guess here's
the thing here's the thing
washington dc there is no justice in
washington dc the dc justice system has
been co-opted so much by the left that i
do not doubt for one freaking second
that merrick garland is going to find a
corrupt
corrupt grand jury in dc that is going
to unseal corrupt indictments on donald
trump that for crimes that he never
committed i absolutely believe that 100
because they want to stop him they know
they've seen the polls showing that he
is beating joe biden in 2024 and they
want to stop him and this is the way
that they're gonna do it but that's it's
not gonna work out it's not i don't
think it's gonna work what are they
gonna indict them on they're gonna find
something they're they've said they
weren't going to do it because uh it's a
step over the line they would just
dangle it in front of everybody like oh
we did a search warrant that proves he's
a criminal that's what they're saying
and they wouldn't cross that line but
now what people are saying and i'm
starting to agree because i'm look i'm
not entirely sure
is that the move against trump was so
egregious they have no choice but to
lean into it otherwise it just looks
political so they have to come up with
something to justify why they did they
have spent six years searching for a
crime yeah in every other and trying to
fabricate some well
yeah they fabric you know they
fabricated evidence to justify spying on
trump and kevin kleinsmith i believe his
name is uh received a one-year probation
sentence
and not only that but he got his law
he's now has his law license backed by
the dc bar in good standing that's crazy
and then there's the then there's the
other fbi lawyer what the hell the guy
who just got acquitted what the heck's
his name he got he he he altered
evidence in an email to he altered he
was another guy who altered evidence to
justify spying and he just got acquitted
for it he even though it was in his
crime was in writing and a dc jury that
consisted of two hillary clinton donors
and a woman whose daughter went to
school with his daughter
voted to acquit him
the guy's name escapes or michael
sussman that was that's right that's
right and but that's how justice works
in dc if you lie in fisa warrants to
justify illegal spying on your political
opponents you'll get acquitted by a jury
of your donors if you're steve bannon
and you get held in contempt by an
illegitimate congressional committee
they will put you in jail that's how
that's how justice works in dc yeah and
that's why i absolutely think they're
going to indict trump
and then what happens
i mean we're already we we've already
had so much crazy stuff happen in the
past week or so with just the outrage
i mean the guy in ohio for instance a
cincinnati fbi office
what happens didn't he go in with a nail
gun wasn't it because people think that
nail guns can get through a bullet proof
or something like that it's it's it not
that's not a thing one thing that
happens is people turn on tv find out
what's going on and they find shows like
this so it's up to us in a lot of ways
people are kind of well they turn on
youtube changing the tone of the
narrative and tone is big right now
mm-hmm
that's why everyone's coming down i know
i don't i don't know what will happen
but
what i do know is i think it's going to
light an effing fire under the gop base
yes
that's absolutely what it's gonna be i
saw a meme that showed uh a ship that
said mog on it's sinking and a bunch of
rats wearing maga hats were like
panicked and swimming away from it i
don't think that they're all laughing
and then i i responded with with the
poll showing that trump's actually his
polling's improved since the fbi raid
and then they were all just like all the
lefties got depressed like no really
it's like bro you guys have no idea
what's going on to you like well they
haven't had any ideas they're not going
to walk away from trump just because the
fbi is going after him they're going to
rally behind him right and they haven't
had any idea what's going on since 2016.
i mean you remember 2016
the entire media was like the trump
voter who is this trump voter who are
these people
and they still have not figured out who
the trump voters are or why or why
people are so opposed to the going
narrative and the uh and the current
regime and there's and i'll say this
there's only one crime that donald trump
has ever committed only one and that's
beating hillary clinton yeah that is
that was a crime he was never supposed
to do that and they have never been able
to come to terms with that and so
they've that that is his only crime
that's the crime that they're that they
want to take him down for and they're
trying to do it i was watching a
documentary on the nazis last night and
and basically after the first world war
the treaty versailles
annihilated germany took all this
territory put them in massive amounts of
debt so they felt hopeless and when
people feel hopeless they look for a
leader a strong leader to help get them
out of the trouble when you look at the
way people have been persecuted the last
two years and been driven insane with
covet
uh stuff i think that people are like
beginning i'm afraid that people may s
they snag on to a strong man that is
give gives them hope uh gives them a
political you know i don't want to see
another hitler rise to power they've
been like afraid of trump and saying
like he's hitler he said don't turn him
into hitler don't do that to people
don't destroy their hope and their their
will to live because they will look for
a strong man if you do
we just
look at the past bro you see that video
this uh woman from fox posted it
where she's like this is what it's like
when you get to work at three a.m oh my
goodness yes i didn't wait i
all over the place it's new york city
and it's people just beating the hell
out of each other in the street out the
window
it's not one fight it's like a bunch of
fights all over the place it's a bunch
of people freaking out on each other
that was i found that terrifying in part
because okay february 2019 or february
2020 before the pandemic before
everything went crazy i was perfectly
happy to walk around new york city at
three o'clock in the morning nothing
like that was ever happening you never
saw that
well now it's normal now you have open
air now rockets yeah homeless cities
like screw eric adams like he ran
like he ran on cleaning this crap that's
why he won that's why he won yeah that
is literally why he won and instead he's
focused on uh he's focused on going to
texas to campaign against greg abbott
because
he's
billboards in florida about like how gay
people are welcome in new york as if
anybody in the world didn't know that
anybody
who still lives in new york i mean
you've got a question
oh my god
no pressure
we've been telling libby to get out of
there for a while move moved i live in
virginia virginia's great we have a
republican governor we have the state
the only the only state uh body that's
going to control virginia is better west
virginia okay i agree with that yeah
but i really quite like west virginia
but yeah it's beautiful it's gorgeous
but move chickens if you can little
rolling hills yeah the lush greenery you
go up on the mountain and there's like
chickens just like everywhere wow like
like quite literally like walking around
you mean outside chicken city they've
escaped or they're just colonizing when
you go into the neighborhoods in west
virginia into like the communities if
you're just like driving down the road
chickens are like
yeah just out i had to get out of the
car and usher one off the street so i
didn't i was in new hampshire recently
we were driving around and new hampshire
is
also very beautiful and we're driving
around new hampshire and we had to stop
short for a whole mess of turkeys to
cross the street it's so awesome isn't
it great getting away from these awful
cities where people are beating the crap
we rented like a little house that had a
pool
crazy not only do they get the crap
eaten out of each other but they'll get
out of jail the next day be from a soros
funded prosecutor that's correct there's
also another video people ransacking at
mcdonald's you see this one yeah wait
did you see the one where it was like
it was like some sort of like late night
snack stand
that these like three women the fries
thing yeah the fries these three like
black women just trashed the place that
was insane that was over the cost of
french fries yeah there was no it was no
sauce it was this costs extra for sauce
and these drunk chicks just they like
jumped up they were like twerking on the
counter yeah and they were like just
throwing cr like that's not like this
stuff's happening all over though that
that bodega owner who uh yeah jose jose
alba because a woman came in complain
about the price of oh no this is a
different story and then no yeah woman
came in complaining about the price of
chips or something had a knife he said
get out she comes out with her boyfriend
they start fighting she stabs the store
owner he stabs the guy while they're
fighting he gets arrested they let him
out he fled didn't i think he went back
well well didn't puerto rico or no no no
no caribbean
yeah somewhere in the caribbean didn't
they like for a short time take his
passport away too i don't know because
they
they had him murder charges they put him
in rikers yeah they put him in reichert
like in a soros fundamentally you're not
allowed to talk about how george soros
spends a lot of money to elect he is
culture has collapsed it's all look it
used to be that people had scruples and
wanted to do what was right it used to
be that when someone committed a crime
they'd be like we gotta stop this and
try and make sure the society can
function these days it's just like don't
know don't care to a judge
that's what you get i remember i got
pulled over when i was like 18
and kappa said i was speeding i wasn't
speeding and he just says i don't care
talk to a judge and that like that's the
way it is they don't know you they don't
care about you and if your life is
ruined they could get that was in
chicago that guy's trying to fill his
quota for the month
chicago is so crooked yeah i got my
license suspended and then i couldn't
drive for a couple years oh my goodness
because chicago is as corrupt as they
come in you know i really hate chicago i
really really despise the place and i
try to avoid going there it is i've been
to so many places around the world i
would rather be in like a brazilian
favela than chicago chicago operated
black sites where they would kidnap
people and torture them there was a
famous that for a long time there was a
guy who was electrocuting people into
forced confessions that's right i've had
such crazy stuff happen to me in chicago
i'm just like bro you do not want it and
i've never been to chicago i feel the
same way about my home city as well i'm
from philadelphia philadelphia has
become a mess like oh you're from philly
yeah i went to high school in
philadelphia where'd you go in high
school uh germantown friends oh really
yeah nice i went to the holy ghost pratt
oh nice yeah um
but uh no but there was like
philadelphia you see a crazy murder
story coming out of philadelphia at
least like once a day like i remember
there was one last week or the week
before there was this guy who grew up in
philly and he moved to las vegas and he
came home to attend a friend's funeral
who had been shot and killed because
that's a thing that happens in philly
every single day because we have a
corrupt soros-funded district attorney
and a terrible mayor and this guy came
home to attend his friend's funeral who
got shot and killed and he proceeded to
get shot and killed
oh my goodness as he was visiting home
and yet so like and like the mayor has
just become a ridiculous person jim
kenney who's the mayor of philadelphia
you may remember when he shut down
indoor dining in the city and then
proceeded to go to a get caught going to
a restaurant in new jersey but he after
after the remember the fourth of july
shooting that happened that was crazy it
was right on the it was right on the
parkway yeah so the fireworks were going
on and there was a shooting like as the
fireworks were happening so it was just
complete chaos but they interviewed jim
jim kenny goes on local news after this
and lily just says he i'm not even
joking he says i am looking forward to
not being here anymore and it's like
he really wanted out it's like screw you
dude if you're not willing to deal with
the realities of crime in your city why
the [ __ ] are you the mayor
yeah why is he the mayor if he doesn't
want to actually fight but what sucks is
they're going to elect another mayor
just like him probably doing it
yes you just got to leave they need
frank or his opponent i mean
the other one could he get worse like
the other option is militant like
militants like more cops on the street
with armored you know what kind of right
so in the early 90s when giuliani came
in to fix up new york city
um there were more cops like the
difference was so transparently clear it
was sort of amazingly clear so i used to
hang out in washington square park it
was always a total disaster you know you
walk through the park whatever
everyone's offering you drugs every five
minutes you know as you walk through the
park
uh almost overnight there was a big
mobile police unit at the bottom of the
park
um on washington square south there were
cops everywhere and suddenly you weren't
getting offered drugs anymore you'd walk
like all through downtown and it was you
know people just kept getting pushed out
to the edges pushed out to the edges
finally giuliani moved the entire red
light district out to queens which
hasn't been great for queens admittedly
um
but yeah it changed overnight giuliani
cleaned up the city and then bloomberg
came in and paid for everything and the
city was great after that what do you
mean paid for everything um well we had
we had a low crime city
so he was able to get a lot of
investment in he was able to get a lot
of businesses to come back in
then he used all that tax money to fund
big parks projects so he built up the
outer boroughs he did this massive parks
program
and it was really nice yeah
i support large-scale police activity if
it's done judiciously but what they did
stop and frisk well what what is like an
insanely sad thing to me happening in
america since the summer of love that
occurred in 2020 is
from like the 1990s to like through the
the 2010s
violent crime in america consistently
went down like you wouldn't see that
like if you followed the media which
constantly likes to elevate this [ __ ]
you wouldn't see that but violent crime
in america went down for two decades and
it has gone back up over the last three
years because
liberal da's have decided to not enforce
the law in order to appease rich radical
progressive activists who don't have to
deal with the realities of the policies
that they advocate for but the people
who are hurt by this and the reason eric
adams won is because poor you know
working class
middle working class people in new york
city who actually have to deal with the
realities of crime every day voted for
him because he was the tough on crime
candidate and obviously he hasn't done
that which has been a major
disappointment but we are literally
reversing decades of decrease in violent
crime in order to appease the worst
elements of our of of our society and
it's an incredibly sad thing cities once
great american cities like chicago and
like philadelphia are being destroyed
once and it's it's the saddest thing
ever
philadelphia i don't know about chicago
it was it's been run by the mob for over
100 years well i'm just saying like ours
we have great cities like you know we
need like we have great cities and
they're being destroyed by this ideology
i'll tell you chicago is great
because of the mafia right like some of
the greatest stories about the old bank
robbers and stuff really bad stuff
really horrifying stuff but it creates a
a legend and a mythos around the city
that makes it somewhat interesting but
uh
chicago's reputation is and always has
been pure corruption okay maybe chicago
you know why they call it the windy city
because there's a lot of wind because
the politicians are blowing hot air
because it is very windy
it's actually not that's actually no i
thought it was windy really no yeah i
lived there three years i've only been
to chicago sometimes because you have a
lake it's like not particularly windy
it's it's it's like maybe slightly above
average but you wouldn't and it's
something all of people in chicago know
it's called the windy city because the
politicians are lying that's what it is
okay but maybe chicago is a bad example
but like los angeles san francisco
no but like like hollywood iconic
american cities that have contributed so
much to our culture you can't walk in
l.a anymore without stepping on a
freaking needle or in human places i i
do understand that point but i also got
to point out you know i i talk about
this news article i was reading from uh
it was like glenn beck's studio it's
from like 1870 or something it was about
a guy who's at a bar some guy walked up
to him and put a put a pistol to his
chest and pulled the trigger
like it was way worse crime
was like way worse you you would just
die and you stubbed your toe and you get
an infection it's gotten way better the
issue is it's it's getting relatively
worse from where it was it it was really
really bad it got really good and now
it's getting bad again and we're not
okay with it and we shouldn't be
no we had a standard of living in this
country
in our cities and regression but it has
declined but like what's gonna happen is
the people who have the means to you are
gonna leave these cities and that's and
they take their ta the the tax base goes
away and the people that get hurt the
most are low-income people who are who
can't who don't have the means to move
and are forced to deal with the
realities of this every single day we
need new cities i think too so people
leaving like that whole what is it iron
thing where all these people went
started a new city i like that idea
because you can start at high tech well
yeah we have great we still have great
cities in america that people can move
to
like what was it
yeah yeah like uh cuyahoga falls ohio
for instance phenomenal city on the
river all the rich people all the all
the mer people of great merit also even
make our own secrets well and no one has
to go to work anymore everyone should
just work in there all the rich people
can just work in their house and we just
started amazon drone deliveries did you
buy your metaverse land package yeah we
just start we just start communes of
people leaving leaving crime in cities
they did that right you know like new
harmony yeah but you know what's really
fun something that i learned recently
that i thought was pretty wild is that
it is now more expensive to live in
miami than new york city and it's not
because of like the crazy housing
policies they have in new york city it's
because so many people are moving there
like west palm beach which is where my
company is based out of and where most
of my co-workers live in order to
qualify for a single apartment by
yourself you need to have they they say
that they like the minimum salary per
year you need to have is like over a
hundred thousand dollars which is like
the top like two percent of income
earners we're gonna go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com for that
uncensored after hours show which goes
up at about 11 pm
and let's read we got this one from
jenny cash wow the johnny cash as a
clanker i have to ask when tf is sticks
going to be on the show i'm a monthly
subscriber and demand this or else
al-balaxia uh styx has an open
invitation to come on the show whenever
he wants correct and we even cover
travel and accommodation so it's just an
issue of
the moment stick says he's coming on the
show we will get his flights we will get
his room and board we will buy him a
fine steak dinner he is absolutely i'm a
big fan six is fantastic
smart guy
uh cali de french says shout out to mini
desk ian you the real mvp of tim cast
iron are you talking about this guy
right here that's right he's in the vlog
look at this he yeah he made his i said
ian has a miniature version of himself
on his desk
thanks for sending this to me by the way
whoever did that it was beautiful it's
like a voodoo doll
country tart says this has to be bret
bayer's son
i so my my girlfriend has been texting
me because she's been watching the show
and she's like every other comment is
somebody who says that you're brett
baer's son and i've never heard i've
never uh
gotten that i've never had someone say
that i look like that before until until
tonight i've never heard that before
interesting all right ultima sandoval
says wyoming beer melvin and alpine
mountain hops and casper bonds and
laramie and many many more i would love
to acquire me some of that good wyoming
beer and we would celebrate wyoming
doing the right thing
the right thing for this country and
they absolutely did that's right 100
right now the heroes of this country
wyoming residents yes except for those
28 percent
i think most of them were democrats
though because right there's a big story
that a lot of democrat like democrats in
wyoming like the democrat party in
wyoming was getting a lot of democrats
to register as republicans so they could
vote for liz cheney we were talking
about that before this is actually
interesting uh anwar abu bakr says
doesn't that mean liz cheney planned on
losing if she referenced the loss of
abraham lincoln and her speech
immediately after losing i can't imagine
she didn't already have the speech
planned and the great task is already up
which requires development with the logo
you don't just look you don't just one
day ago hey can i get a website that
shows these things can fundraise has
these looks no that takes a couple weeks
they usually work on a loss and a win
they'll have t-shirts printed for both
or whatever like like i said earlier she
gave up a long time ago when being
reelected she treated this whole thing
as as a griff to raise money for an
eventual presidential run that will also
be a giant grift and nobody will vote
for her except in except in north and
probably in the beltway valley says
trump yells nuclear ultra maga whenever
he goes super saiyan 3.
that's right three he skips right over
one and two that's right
really now says still waiting on libby
to agree to get dinner with me
yeah libby what are you doing libby what
don't even know who that is
come on women unnecessary risk
all right
amos moses says ian said in february he
was going to start going to the gym and
get jacked we want meathead ian and buff
pool i i think about i lost a lot of
weight you know so i'm i do the
occasional plank and i like i play i
play hard when i play i think i think i
think ian you guys aren't lifting i know
dude it'll be thinking that for 20 years
but just imagine what it'll be like it's
like
in in in january people watching the
show just see like this super just jack
that's the thing because they'll be like
i hate this guy so annoying i don't
understand it and then they see me with
my shirt off and they're like ah
you know but wouldn't like this guy when
you start lifting you'll get a massive
increase in testosterone and then also
be more commanding on stage yeah and
you'll just be like
yeah trump fix it
here's the solution all right i wouldn't
even be angry about it
you could do the mussolini thing
you could go to the royal you could just
write up too and be even more
i think they provide that at the
children's hospital if a your
if you think that it's part of your
gender identity sure dapper mcstache
says ian newsweek reports the laser
ignition facility in california just
confirmed its first ever self-sustaining
ignition
self-sustaining ignition sorry i didn't
mean interrupt the last part fusion on
the way you excited yet
i'm extremely excited but the thing
about fusion has been on the way for 30
years um and it would be very disruptive
to the power structure if everyone had
their own unlimited power supply but i
am very excited about it now you said
it's consistent ignition i thought they
were able to ignite it then it went back
off self-sustaining meaning it's on but
that was like a year ago no no no no
they recently did a new thing it was in
newsweek yeah i'm pretty sure it's like
it's yeah they they were able to
recreate that first thing
but it but ignition
ultimately fizzles out is different from
a self-sustaining like keeping
self-sustaining nuclear fusion
science alert from yesterday that's huge
man now they ca but but now they can't
replicate it see this is what they said
yeah that's what the article says this
is titled the article well it was i
think it was last week and so now they
tried it again and they couldn't do it
this is just an article from yesterday
i'm definitely going to read it but
you'll see that i was reading about this
like last week it's normal yeah you'll
try a bunch of things one will work in
the book okay what did i do like how did
that happen
and they also with high-tech military
tech they'll do something like we went
to the moon we don't think it can be
replicated uh just so no one else tries
to do it because as soon as everyone
starts doing it then we've got it's like
it's like an ocean it's like an iron man
when when he's telling everybody they
can't have the arc reactor but then that
dude from russia shows up with the arc
reactor and starts screwing everybody up
in monaco exactly right you know
marvel analogies just got to do it you
know
just shove it in that's right pop
culture reference right there
all right
what do we have what do we have some
super chats
okay
paul thongham says notice that tim
sometimes references south park and he
plays magic the gathering tim also owns
chickens if you get the if you
understand the episode i'm thinking of
you should do chicken city short called
chicken magic
uh-huh
do you guys know that episode of south
park i've been watching themselves the
roosters they're they're having roosters
playing match together against each
other oh underground
yeah like like illegal cockfighting
all right
let's see slain hope says ian conquering
people is in our nature denying that is
to deny the history of humanity morality
and humanity aren't as compatible as
some would like to believe that's why
people go to church thank you for
bringing that up people all these people
talking about being pro-life and that
they're pro-life and obsessed with
babies that are one week old like
where's your anti-war stance if you're
pro-life where are you caring about the
people in afghanistan that were left
behind when we surrendered wait wait
wait wait talk about those those people
overwhelmingly are well i want to go i
want to hear them talk about capital
they do i would like to hear them make
that the focus of the conversation is
pro-life shouldn't you be opposed to
capital punishment yes no obviously i
mean but the thing is to be extreme in
all situations that i will protect life
at all costs makes no sense it's like
especially with this
this is why at 10cast.com we don't use
pro-life or pro-choice we say
pro-abortion or anti-abortion yeah
that's because they're they're used in
that context
so
i i i the challenge with pro-life is for
one if you're trying to use it as an
absolute statement then fine that you
should oppose a death penalty but people
who are pro-life are typically mean
trying to say that they would protect
life at all costs
except when an individual
has taken it like someone on death row
so the argument is
you can be pro-life but agree that
someone who committed a crime and
through due process has forfeited theirs
but another another problem with the
death penalty though is that there have
been a remarkable number of cases that
have shown that the person who was
executed or on death row didn't actually
do it so people
yeah we do not have a perfect justice
system which means we should not be
taking life on its bases i just put it
this way um i don't think people like
kamala harris should be the arbiter who
arbiter who gets to live and die she
shouldn't be the arbiter of literally
who gets a sandwich with mayo and who
gets one with mine
just thinking about death row in general
a lot of people talk about the the very
very severe like harsh standard to
actually get someone the death penalty
and i'm still just like i get it man you
know if i saw i have no problem with
in in defense of others or yourself you
know taking someone else's life it's
unfortunate it's tragic we don't want it
to happen but if some dude is about to
like kill a kid or whatever you got to
stop him you got to save you got to stop
the aggressor
but if you've already stopped them you
know then i'm just like
the the issue for me is i totally get
that person you know did something bad
and is trying to do it again and you
stopped them
my challenge is when i walk into a
courtroom and it's someone like kamal
harris going trust me that guy's bad and
should die i'll be like no i don't trust
you you're nuts and kamala harris and
ian i just want to point out that i am
both pro-life and very anti-neo-con and
anti-war
the neocons stuck and we need to purge
them from society
the yemen the sales of weapons to saudi
arabia by trump really disturbs me
because they are just slaughtering the
yemeni people i mean there's it's mass
starvation
50
of their population or something is like
under
25 or something because the rest have
starved to death yeah
and there was war and the whole thing we
got a good one triton 54. we got to get
an award for this he says breaking news
after her monumental defeat in an effort
to minimize her carbon footprint and
become more appealing to climate
activists liz cheney was seen writing
her broomstick from dc wyoming
that's a good one
what i would i would revise that to say
she she rode her broomstick from wyoming
back to suburban virginia where she's
lived her entire life yeah
says tim you're wrong in general parents
should be allowed to determine the best
for their children but that isn't
without limits example we allow parents
to discipline but not to abuse my point
was like to democrats if you don't give
a vaccine to your kid you're abusing
them and you're a dangerous anti-vaxxer
and the government should take your kids
away and to the right if you're giving
them sex change surgery quite literally
the same thing you're abusing them the
government should intervene the point is
you have look i clearly think the left
is wrong but you have uh disparate world
views and the question about when the
government gets to intervene is a scary
one because that will be used against
you at some point and i mean it
literally is being used against parents
right now when in texas with the with
the younger thing where they take the
guy's kid from him or they try to that's
that's scary stuff man well and in dc if
you don't get your kid vaccinated your
kid can't go to school which is like
like remember when
you know georgia was passing their
voting law and like biden was saying
that this is jim jim makes jim crow look
like jimmy eagle
40
of black students in dc are not going to
be allowed to go back to school this
fall
is that not making jim crow look like
jimmy eagle like and there was a
reporter from the daily signal who asked
muriel bowser about this the other day
his name is douglas blair
and
she was basically like i don't that's
not true what you're saying is lie and
it was literally he was literally citing
numbers from dc saying that 40 percent
of black kids in dc are unvaccinated
john rafa says tim charlie kirk posted a
training video of armed irs agents you
will not believe no i saw that did you
guys see that yeah i saw that
that was going around everywhere the irs
criminal investigation division or
whatever and they're doing a training
video they walk in and they're like
don't move and it's like two guys with
like fake weapons being like what's
going on i'm not moving oh i did see
them yeah yeah
oh man
all right philip vecchio says that part
that was part of the plot of the
original manchurian candidate the son in
an incestuous relationship with his
mother played by angela lansbury oh
gross
wow
awful awful
angela linsberry is great though
cody bridger says in most cases the
parents are just as much of the victims
as their children it is the doctors who
are abusive for performing mutilation on
minors what happened to do no harm
someone an interesting interesting
question i mean
there are some cultures
you know let's i'll throw it to the
orville reference we mentioned before
seth mcfarland an episode where
one alien race performs sex chain
surgery on girls because they don't have
girls in their planet because they
force transition them
and they say
you know the alien guy says if a child
was born with a cleft lip would you not
correct it we view it the exact same way
and so you know
with this you have
genital mutilation in a bunch of
countries where like female circumcision
and things like that are considered
wrong must be stopped we saw a wave of
that happening in um
i think in dearborn in the dearborn area
i'm not sure i i loved the
matt walsh's documentary what is a woman
when he went to that random african
tribe and asked them what they thought
about the idea that men could become
women and they were just laughing at him
yeah but so so i guess the issue is
you know circumcision in general be it
male or female well so did you see that
andrew sullivan tweet from like
yesterday so andrew sullivan the former
new york times reporter
he was like what do all the people who
disagree with sex changes think about
circumcision
and he got like and he got like
monumentally racial because like i don't
think both i don't i think those are too
close pretty different things but it is
a form of well you could argue genital i
mean it is i don't know mutilation is
the right word but you're cutting up a
baby's penis without its the kid's not
like asking for it and then a lot of
decisions and like half the nerves are
removed and it's an old process from
2000 years ago when it was a cleanliness
thing like it would become too dirty and
then they'd get infected so they had to
remove the outer layer of skin so it's
easier to clean i think that's the
purpose that might be what they say but
i i don't know if it's that specific now
it's just like a tradition i don't even
know what it does but i think i think
that would be similar to saying like if
you're if you're in favor of haircuts do
you also support decapitation
i think those are two kind of different
things all right let's read this one
sorry for lot says
tim your nancy pelosi impression is my
favorite thing in the world let's hear
it i haven't heard it the donald trump
is a disgusting awful man and he needs
to be impeached i will not stand for
this it's getting older in real time do
you feel like it's you absolutely
you gotta like do the thing where she
like her dentures like are falling out
too yeah that's that's why i try to
signal like
about donald trump he's so awful and
then i'm gonna go create some stuff and
i'm gonna trade some stocks
now we're gonna go trade stocks and
become rich on a 170 000 a year salary
so wow also it's like pablo so you're
gonna get charged with the dui or you
think he's gonna have his charges
dropped of course well he got charged
did he did he get charged i don't
remember it but he got charged yeah i
don't know but is it i i wasn't the
story that he was drunk and someone hit
him
he hit a jeep he hit it i don't know i
read something no he hit a yeah he hit a
jeep with his porsche i'm pretty sure
you want you wanna you wanna pull that
out yeah we should check that because i
thought it was a case of like he was
driving drunk and then someone hit him
and it makes it his fault because he was
drunk you know what i mean
like if you're drunk and you're pulling
out and someone hits you it's your fault
you know what i mean
i don't know yeah maybe hit somebody
all right
let's see
a free thinking dog says no man would
request a woman to get an abortion
agreed i saw that viral meme where it's
like progressive men aren't men as
exemplified by the face on the hands
thing you see that one yeah like there's
like a it's like a picture of a shocking
moment and and the women and like some
of the men are going like with their
hands over their mouths and i was like i
don't know you know i mentioned this
before when i was flying on a plane from
wellington to auckland and we got hit by
like 70 mile an hour winds and the plane
fell like 100 feet or something
all the women on the plane instantly
started screaming at top of their lungs
not a single man screamed
and i was like huh made me think i
screamed when there was a stink bug on
the mic one time and why is that i don't
know
men and women are different women scream
men don't scream women signal i read
that
that women on average cry once a month
and men on average cry once a year once
a month that's it
i gotta be honest i can't remember the
last time i cried about anything
i'm pretty sure i cried last week
i don't even know why it was the last
time you cried i was on the show uh like
a month ago when i was talking about god
i was starting to feel it but it wasn't
like i wasn't deeply like losing it or
anything yeah what about you greg i'm
gonna make my group chat with my friends
uh laugh out loud right now because the
last time i cried is when my friend
jordan chamberlain and will chamberlain
you've had them on their show at their
wedding i cried during their wedding
because it was a gorgeous wedding and
jordan and jordan's one of my best
friends and so i was like jordy's
getting married this is so this is so
adorable
oh see there you go no i cried watching
a video of my son when he was little
saying something with his little cute
kid voice
that's what it was and then i showed it
to him and then he cried oh wow
all right psychotator says it was my
fault because i was crying and then that
made him upset i would like to point out
that i have used ian's graphene plan to
change the minds of at least three
climate activists so thank you ian for
pointing that out and thank all of you
this show is my favorite source of
actual news thank you very much
fantastic see you change three people's
minds that's a good that's a good ratio
that's how it all starts the real power
of graphene to change hearts and minds
yeah so what would the which person is
referencing i don't know why i thought
that she he or she is referencing is uh
that we can pull the carbon dioxide out
of the atmosphere and convert it into
graphene by running it through well
there's different ways to do you can
deposit onto a metal like gold palladium
or copper or you could run it through uh
there's another chemical that i think
that we're working on right now i've
been working with a company that does it
you can also take the methane out of the
air converted into carbon dioxide and
then turn that into graphene all right c
says the soul is gendered it travels
here from a distance when a baby is
aborted the soul cannot join the body
the soul joins the next available body
and therefore transgender population
increases
interesting i have an idea for an idea
for a horror movie that sounds like
something a conservative or christian
group would make but no like actual
hollywood
production company would make
and so here i'm leaving my i'm gonna
give you guys my pitch
so here's how the movie starts
it's late
9 p.m 10 p.m it's dark office building
30th floor corner office you can see the
windows
an older woman is working in the office
and she's clearly working late and
putting in those hours because she wants
that promotion
and then as she's working and taking a
phone call you see a figure walk past
your door it's it's totally dark right
the lights are off the office is closed
but she's working late and a figure
walks past the door the hallway door
just like the door to the to the room
full of cubicles and whatever in her
corner office because she's she's a
working woman she's a corner office you
know she got promotion and then she's
sitting there and then while she's
working and she's like writing things
down and typing the figure walks by
again and she notices and she goes
hello
she gets up and she looks around she
doesn't see anything and she goes back
to work
and then she's typing and she's looking
down
this figure walks into the room starts
walking towards her
and then finally
the shadow and the light so it's coming
over and she looks up and it is a human
body pure white with no face no no
expression no features just like a white
almost like plastic looking entity and
it looks at her it just goes
and then it cuts to the start of the
movie and here's the premise of the
movie
souls are supposed to be on the planet
for a certain amount of time
mass abortion is a new phenomenon
and so the souls that were supposed to
develop into lives and create generate
personalities and experiences were
severed from those bodies by being
killed early so whereas a ghost is
created when a person is killed in an
untimely fashion and they have
unfinished business the souls that were
never able to actually exist and be born
start growing and expanding as
personalityless souls and then over time
people start reporting more and more
sightings of these strange figures being
seen throughout the city and then in the
end there's just like a mass immersion
of these strange entities all over the
place and people are freaking out and
society's collapsing and you know it's
funny because i think it's like a cool
idea but it's so pro-life that like i'm
sure the left would vomit and then no
hollywood company would go anywhere near
it but only issue i've got is that i
don't think mass abortions are new i
think it's been happening since the dawn
of time and now we have a spotlight well
there used to be more infanticide too
yeah but but it is it is new procedural
like yeah like i think i think easier so
i think so
maternal
like survival rates for a long like for
until like the early 1900s were very low
and so you know a lot of women and
babies would die in childbirth oh that
was that was that was that was
you know that was more prevalent back
then and you're pointing out libby that
they would give birth and then kill the
infant right away rather than try and do
anything internal i get it that makes
sense
all right let's grab some more super
chats
somebody wants to make that movie
i think it's a cool concept for like a
horror film
libby is your ego blowing up right now
at the amount of super chats of people
telling you you're beautiful
i'm like real very weird i'm like
reading them and i'm like every other is
like libby you're so beautiful that's
very kind
we love it
stacy strickland says what came first
the chicken or the egg the egg that's
it's it's a definitive answer but did
you ever hear um what mother teresa said
about abortion when she was asked
she was asked um
why jesus hadn't come again and she said
god um she said or whatever she said
like
you keep aborting him
oh geez spicy so just to clarify the egg
thing uh the way evolution works the
modern chicken came from an egg from a
not
like yeah it's like there's a slow
change process where
so the egg has been around for a very
very like first of all eggs have been
around before chickens so if you're
talking generally about eggs but in
terms of chicken egg chicken evolved in
the like in the process of being bred
there you go answer to your question
like the first chicken was a mutation
exactly so there was like a a choking
which had a mutant smaller weird-looking
thing that we call a chicken actually it
was the i think the red jungle fowl
was uh what ultimately we we turned into
the chicken so the egg came first and
then we started selectively breeding
until chickens came out i'm gaining uh
an unexpected amount of joy of your
knowledge of chickens these days
these days i've known a lot about
chickens forever oh really yeah the way
the way so here's what happened in
southeast asia the uh i think it's the
red jungle fowl it could be wrong they
the reason they lay eggs every day is
because they evolved in bamboo forests
where once every 15 year 50 years
there's a blossom and all the seeds fall
down at once and there's food everywhere
so what would happen is the jungle fowl
the population would explode with the
mass amount of food and then slowly
start falling and then explode and the
first thing that happened was
they were they were domesticated to
fight each other for entertainment the
males would be taken and then they'd
make them fight but eventually word made
its way across asia that there was a
bird that laid an egg every single day
and it actually became like a symbol
like almost a religious symbol because
it produced an egg every day and then
people were like you know if you just
give it food it will lay an egg every
single day and it's like that's actually
pretty awesome because we like eating
them and so then this is like i think
around like the 900s a.d or whatever
then they started turning them into like
an actual staple farm you know animal
gosh i can't imagine life without
chickens silky's one of the first breeds
yeah the fluffy ones those are cute yeah
and they're they have five toes and
their their their their chicken meat is
actually black
wow and they're skinny blue weird yeah
how do they taste have you eaten them
i've not eaten one and they're fluffy we
have we actually have a bunch
interesting yeah they have domed heads
though so there's like you can't put
them with a regular another rooster will
peck his head and kill him right away
yeah yeah you know chickens man chicken
society is a crazy thing
chicken society
jukebox says brought up ndaa
whistleblower from dod on the 15th
what is that about i'm not sure
all right we love we love our based
whistleblowers though
ryan kirchmeier says real men coerce
women not to get abortions i did that
best thing i ever did he's now 10 she's
glad i did too would have been her third
the other two were not me wow so that is
so those are the stories that we hear
about all the time that the media and
democrats never talk about and they're
always beautiful stories
so good on you man that's that's awesome
yeah i mean a dude saying like he's
gonna take responsibility and and
protect the woman and help raise the kid
that's what a real man would do
now i had a situation where a girl i was
dating a girl when she got pregnant and
she told me she was gonna leave me and
abort the kid in the middle of a fight
and i was like abort it now don't wait
don't don't hold it over my head don't
threaten me and kill it before it grows
a brain because it was like two weeks
old or something yikes
it was horrifying and then it died on
its own that's sad it hurt my voice
that's awful i'm sorry i'm sorry about
that yeah
all right
patriot text says 50 years of more
relativism taught in our schools endless
wars killing our best patriotic youth
and churches that are businesses and not
preaching biblical values yes culture is
collapsing you see that video of the the
preacher being like you couldn't even
give me your mcdonald's money your red
lobster money you see that one
he was like yelling at his congregation
because they didn't give him enough
money he wanted to buy a watch or
something like that then he should
apology
at least that's how it was reported
you know
raymond g stanley jr says the regressive
left
i think bill maher just talked about the
regressive left for like the for like
the first time ever
and it's kind of funny to hear him say
like 10 years after the phrase is like
moved out of or you know like seven
years he said he did he did a bit about
what's going on with wokeness and he
says this is regressive and i was like
oh
bill finally said it he said the law
back wow yeah he's late to the party but
you know always late
lumpy says women have all the control
when it comes to abortion men have none
your claim libby is unfounded unless men
have suddenly gained the right to
financially abort children i love you
libby but when it comes to abortion
women have all the choice
uh i beg to differ well i mean it's it's
legally
sure sure but like in terms of you know
human bonding a woman still has the
right to choose like sure the guy can
coerce her and she could say yes or no
do you guys i mean okay just do you guys
have any idea how much influence a man
in a romantic
partnership has over the woman that he's
with regardless of anything she says
about like i'm in charge of everything
in my own life do you have any idea
you may have absolutely no idea i mean
that's the ask any woman but that's that
she'll let you know i'm pretty sure men
are in relationships right like i've
been in relationships and i know the
degree of control that i have you you
may not and but it varies okay sure it
varies but like
um like there are some relationships
children do whatever they want sure and
like ian mentioned they might be like
i'm gonna go do this you can't stop yeah
there's there's um
there's many women that i know who have
been coerced into abortions by men that
they love this happens one of the top
reasons this happens a lot but the
ultimate point regardless of what the
law says but and regardless of what
regardless of rights regardless of
anything because ultimately the man can
say whatever he wants the woman can
always just say i'll do whatever i want
yeah right sure a man still has
absolutely no control other than
persuasion yeah
he can try to convince the woman but the
woman can say yes or no you might be
right because like men are genetically
prone to impregnate lots of women this
is just for the propagation of the
species tens of thousands of years ago
and so it's probably easier for them to
disconnect and be like whatever but the
girl you're saying that there's more of
like a i can't let go of this man like
this man is part of me now kind of mind
are you kidding yes are you kidding like
yeah yeah
yeah that's a yeah but that's that's the
thing that's like still not like uh
to maintain a bond is different from not
having control i'm not saying she
doesn't have control i'm not saying
coercion means you don't have control
you can be coerced right you can be
coerced into something even if you you
know feel like you're in control the
whole time many women that i know have
been coerced into abortions there's
nothing we can do to change that that's
true like that's just true
i mean that's just actually true and yes
like uh
it it's have you ever read the
statistics on um women leaving abusive
relationships
it typically takes seven tries for a
woman to leave an abusive relationship
um it takes a whole lot of stuff just in
a practical sense but emotionally
it's an excruciatingly difficult process
to disentangle
from someone that you're in love with
who treats you badly like this happens
over and over again
all right it's it's real that's real in
my world we castrate all the men who do
that well you know what there'd be like
a lot of [ __ ] individuals walking
around there are a lot of differences
all right everybody
just kind of smash the like button smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com grab that
members only uncensored show for you
coming up at about 11 p.m and you can
follow the show at tim cast irl you can
follow me at tim cast greg you want to
shout anything out yeah my twitter
account's uh greg underscore price11 and
greg.price11 on instagram um you know
we're i'm you know deep into the fight
for the midterms fight to take back the
house and elect a lot of america first
candidates so follow me to keep track of
all that because that's that's what i do
every single day
uh i'm libby emmons you can find me at
the post millennial also you can check
out our opinion columns at
humanevents.com i'm at libya emmons on
twitter and libby.emins on instagram i'm
ian crossland i love you all so much i
love you we love youtube make it real
make it rain
do we not love ian for all the farmers
imagine not loving ian bring that right
love yourself
and the rest will fall out
and we are using our npr voices to say
goodbye so thank you all very much for
tuning in this evening you guys can
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlist.me this has been a
production of tim cast
episodes are available on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com bye guys
you